hey man it's me kevin smith look at me
my funny goofy hat don't i look like
hella from thor don't you sometimes just
want to club that kevin smith well how
about instead you joined that kevin
smith club oh my god we've been having
such a good time we have hours of audio
kids in the smodcast podcast archives
that you can stick into your ear holes
and listen to or do you want to look at
something are you one of them dirty
[ __ ] well then go to the smithstoneian
screening room where you can watch
hundreds of hours of video of my entire
career spanning from the beginning up
until now including my daily morning
show wake and bake man will we just
smoke weed hang out and i tell you what
i'm working on plus there's exclusive
events we've had clerks 3 screenings for
our club members we've had smod castle
exclusive shows for our members back in
jersey we do events all the time
including movies pop-ups and there's
tons of merchandise of course that that
kevin smith club members get exclusive
access to before anybody else there are
so many ways into that kevin smith club
ladies and gentlemen you don't have to
come through the front door you can come
through the back door we like it that
way sign up as a clerk where you get
access to all the audio that we got or
join as a mall rep that gives you all
the audio and all the video as well or
join as a fun employee ladies and
gentlemen you'll get a new t-shirt an
exclusive that kevin smith club t-shirt
every quarter or join as a yoga hoser
and get yourself something cool like
that kevin smith waking bake bowl ladies
and gentlemen those are our existing
levels but what about the new levels
that's right for 2022 we've added some
levels including the fashionable mail
you get everything that the clerk the
mall rat the yoga hoser and the fun
employee gets but you also get once a
year an exclusive piece of wardrobe from
a kevin smith film straight out the
viewers universe from the secret stash
archives or join as a brand new ranger
danger man that gives you everything
that the clerk the mall rat the fun
employee and the yoga hoser gets as well
as what the fashionable male gets but
then you also once a year get an
exclusive prop direct from one of my
movies and if you've got untold riches
coming out of your ass guess what holy
cow there's the golden calves level man
for that level you come to my house i
cook you dinner we record a podcast and
we shoot it for wake and bacon it goes
up on smodcast man very exclusive once a
year we do that join us at
thatkevinsmithclub.com be a clerk be
them all right be a fun employee be a
yogas or be a fashionable male be a
ranger danger or be a golden calf ladies
and gentlemen i'll be waking and baking
for you come join me at that kevin smith
club
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is it live over here i think we're live
um hey kids hey man it's friday night
um [ __ ] in hollywood for heaven's
sake so you know god how do we begin the
show i got
ovid may have taken some memories from
me mark oh no it burns him away
um welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i am mark bernardin hey
there it is oh we did it i found it good
job um kids as previously uh referenced
um i i could not dodge the covet bullet
any longer and uh as of uh this week i i
tested positive for covid
uh tuesday um
monday was fine i had been you know all
over the place i was in
st louis and then florida to go to
disney world and then i was in
minneapolis for v con and then i was in
orlando for mega con so where i got it i
don't know but um
uh monday when i got home i was
fine i tested like i took a test when i
got home
on sunday night like totally fine monday
was fine
tuesday mark oh [ __ ]
it was it's morbid time it was
it was so
i've never felt so [ __ ] up in my life
not like sick or puking or anything like
that but just
so fatigued i've never been so like i
can't [ __ ] move like i just
want to lay in bed i can't and then the
only times i wanted to get up was to go
take a whiz which i was pissing like a
[ __ ] racehorse i guess my body was
trying to get rid of whatever
um and it was a pretty achy
you know
[ __ ]
i felt like
hungover and stoned at the same time
felt drugged it was weird um but by
midnight it was done
and so as of wednesday well as of you
know wednesday at midnight or tuesday at
midnight
i was
walking around like a [ __ ] natural
non-covent individual and [ __ ] just uh
suddenly
i wasn't all achy anymore jennifer got
it from me so she had a she was a day
behind me so that
day she was like i told you to wear a
mask shoe
but um
it was you know look i spent the last
20 20 it kicked in so two years [ __ ]
afraid of this and and it came i was
double vaxxed and double boosted so
that [ __ ] it came into my body
boom it did whatever the [ __ ] it did
inside the vaccine and
walking away man like
[ __ ]
thank god for science yay vaccines and
[ __ ] like that yeah although that amount
of travel is a bit like you know
covering yourself in a steak suit and
running into the bear pit
it's
going to hit you
it's no true and i was i wouldn't say i
was cocky but by i do remember saying
like if i make it home from this [ __ ]
florida trip and i don't have covert i
don't think i'm ever going to have
coping
with it
um but uh yes happy to report that i
survived everyone was very nice
about like oh my god are you okay on the
one tuesday evening even then it was
i felt shitty and i was like so [ __ ]
like
moving was so hard but i it was never
like you know oh i'm puking my guts out
or i got to go to the hospital or
something like that
um but i did add an abundance of caution
we were going to have a live show this
week thank god we canceled that because
that was the day that i
got full blown and i was supposed to do
babylon this weekend on saturday but
i figured like oh i'll be better by then
but
jennifer was like
oh
that's not how that goes yeah she's like
you may spread it by going to do your
funny show funny boy and i was like oh
yeah i guess that wouldn't be so funny
after all cause no uh ralph was kind
enough to uh cancel the show move it to
june or something like that
um but yeah you've been through it
correct i was yeah in january
it entered my house
stayed for about a month
my son caught it then my wife caught it
then my daughter caught it and then i
caught it basically about seven days
apart
yeah wait well once you this is a point
of discussion we've been having around
here
you can't like reinfect each other right
you can't apparently or at least the at
the time the science said that once you
are through it
there's
some relatively temporary but strong
immunities from from reinfecting
other people so like once you've had it
you're not gonna get it right away now i
know people who've had every stripe of
corona they've had the og they've had
the omicron they've had the delta i'm
sure they're gonna get whatever's coming
in from new york that's supposed to hit
us in about a month
um
but but that whole like the house has it
the house will then eventually get
better from it it won't just stick
around like a [ __ ] cold
which i've been in those houses too you
know the the east coast somebody's got a
cold and then everybody's sick until
march
that is something that is very east
coast um
uh
my kid uh she got it and uh because she
she was with me on the road and her
boyfriend austin
and uh
she's still kind of laid up with it and
austin's kind of out of it but um she's
been like guzzling pedialyte somebody
was like hey man get that pedialyte so
she's
drinking that but i like i'm i'm really
happy to report that like you know and
i'm not
down playing and [ __ ] i'm just glad i
got my shots because
i you know i was like oh [ __ ] here we go
batting down the hatches i saw a [ __ ]
article
online a friend reached out to me and
was like jesus are you okay and i was
like yeah why and there's an article i
think in like giant [ __ ] robot or
giant rogue shining about one of those
websites where it was just like kevin
smith has a disease that could kill him
or something like that or
or a condition that could kill him and
i'm like well technically that's true
but
like i've had a condition that can kill
me since i was born it's called being
one
a little on the clickbaity side enough
to get my friend to reach out to me i
was like i'm fine they're like oh [ __ ]
the way this read i thought you were
dying
um but what uh what a travel i've been
on uh good sir i went to uh
um where i was in st louis the other
weekend and then i went to
uh orlando
to florida early in advance of we had a
movies pop-up open up at the tin roof
and then we had
megacon at the end of the week but i
went out early to hang out with my mom
and jason muse came with me from st
louis and his idea was like let's take
your mother to disney world i was like
she don't give a [ __ ] about that my
mother's like i would love to go to
disney world
jason's like that would be amazing and
so
we got
the the uh guide you know you're paying
nobody to bring you around because mom
is she can't walk at all anymore she's
hobbles at best but she's mostly in the
wheelchair now so
you know i was like let's just make this
easy as possible for mom being that she
wants to [ __ ] go but once my kid
heard that like we had a guy he was like
i'm [ __ ] flying out
um
i'm joining us with austin as well so we
went to uh you know the magic kingdom of
course but before we went there
we went to
hollywood studios whatever that was
right
to go on rise the resistance a thing
i've never done okay
i never did it have you done it i did
yeah when i went about three weeks ago
[Music]
right
i mean like i know we're going to talk
about obi-wan kenobi and stuff but like
you want to talk about some excellent
[ __ ] next generation star wars
you're actually in that [ __ ] at one
point they drive you you're in like a
tram thing like an imperial
they drive you into a [ __ ] first
order hanger and you are beneath these
giant attacks snow walkers and they
don't move or anything like that but
the scope of them is so [ __ ] big dude
you feel like
oh my god this is what it would be like
you feel like an action figure what a
fun [ __ ] ride that was and i never
rode the other one either with the
millennium falcon oh yeah yeah
um good times man [ __ ] was good that
[ __ ] the resistance rod 400 million
dollars
you know it's funny like i went on that
ride and i don't really i'm not i'm not
a big roller coaster person i'm not a
big like i i will never do the guardians
like cosmic escape because i was never
the twilight zone tower terror guy i
don't like drops
not that dude yeah i just did that for
the first time because my kid was like
come on please and i was like i don't do
drops i'm like
i don't do job but you talked into it
and it was [ __ ] dope dude yeah it's
good but it is like it's a real drop bro
yeah like
[Music]
but like rise of the resistance has a
drop and i knew it was coming because i
i remembered us getting on an elevator
i'm like we have to go down to get out
and i bet you that's a [ __ ] drop but
the integration of that drop into the
actual tech and the story and the
experience of it was unbelievable it was
so great
good times man um somebody in chat is
just like yet more trash star wars from
disney um
i don't know if they're talking about
kenobi or this ride but let me tell you
something
ain't none trash about that ride like no
they spent money
and you could see it everywhere
everything is [ __ ] life-sized like it
you know i know the point of those parks
is like to feel like a kid again
that that i couldn't believe the whole
time i'm going through that ride i was
like i just want to go back in time and
tell the young me like one day they will
make a ride like you dream about
like where you're gonna [ __ ] see snow
walkers and [ __ ] storm troopers gonna
walk up to you and [ __ ] like oh it was
[ __ ] yeah and it's kind of phenomenal
that like you can draw a straight line
from it's a small world to rise to the
resistance
like
the the
the methodology of the storytelling is
the same we're going to put you in a
cart we're going to convey you through a
world and in that world there will be
entertainment
and the fact that just adding technology
and adding innovation and adding
you know scope and scale and we're
building so [ __ ] much it's
fundamentally the same
narrative structure get in this [ __ ]
boat
very much so and you know what like
anywhere else in the world somebody's
like get in the [ __ ] boat you're like
oh my god i don't want to die
at least from jersey
you don't want to be billy bathgated or
something like that
but uh that being says it deep cuts
reference that being said
um that being said it was um
disney world they can tell me to get in
any boat man
like it still works i'm happy to report
that it still works even better dude was
like
being on rise of resistance
um
i wasn't necessarily
next to my mom i'd look back and see
every once in a while but i was more
like i'm this is for me
um
but we we did the pixar land ride where
it's like you just play games yeah it
was fun
with this 3d glass it's really [ __ ]
cool but i've done it before but mom
had never been and so she like rode
with me and they
if you if you're in the wheelchair place
they bring a special like car over for
you and stuff like that it's pretty
unique system i got
but at one point you know i'm going
through this ride and if you've never
been on it like it's it's like an arcade
and you're playing virtual games and
you've got this gun that's got like a
pull cord on it so your
phone pies your nothing not bang bang
guns it's just like you've got a
shooting gallery thing and the shooting
gallery is 3d because you're wearing
these glasses
one point
i looked over at my mother
and
the joy
in her face my mother's not like a game
player you know what i'm saying like
she's i mean she maybe she's a game
player you know like i play games son
but like not
games like
you know my whole life i've never really
seen my mother
thrill to a
you know
dopey thing like thrilled to her
children and her husband
but like
you know i never saw her even when she's
a wicked driver it was never like ah
joy in her face like i've seen joy in
her face but never like with an activity
or some sort of [ __ ]
um joy from real people and and whatnot
but not from like
just simple self-serving [ __ ] good
old-time
fun
and there i am sitting next to a
76-year-old woman and i looked over and
she was joyously
taking that
chord man and like having a blast she
got a [ __ ] score but like
you know we weren't there for the points
but
that image of her like just lit up like
a child and enjoying herself and [ __ ] um
that that was worth the trip alone it
was bad that's great pretty damn magical
uh they got another ride though
uh this mickey mouse minnie mouse
picnic ride oh it's in what used to be
the great hollywood ride and the fake uh
chinese theater they got in like i guess
out here being california adventure
i'm out there it's in holly disney's
hollywood studios and um it's the the
ride that as much as i love rise of the
resistance the mickey mouse ride really
like captured my imagination because it
feels like a classic disney ride uh one
of their classic dark rides which is you
know all the rides that
go through indoors they call dark rides
um but this felt like
classic but
like if they had this technology when
they opened the park this is what
like mr toads would have looked like it
wouldn't be like two-dimensional
cardboard people it would be projecting
animation
onto the wall that's so realistic that
you feel like you're in a [ __ ]
cartoon
running water is animated like all of it
was [ __ ] spellbinding and not to
mention heartwarming because
you know try to find a mickey mouse
anything
in disney like you know he's their
corporate figurehead but there's
not really like look at his [ __ ] ride
and here
he's got like they got their own [ __ ]
ride it's focused on them it's that new
style of animation they've been doing
mickey and and
i loved it i had a [ __ ] blast so i
did that i went to disney that was nice
uh hung out with mom uh went to
minneapolis that was nice
uh then came back did mega khan which
was
absolutely [ __ ] lovely and then came
home to
open it out but uh if you've not seen
rise of the resistance yet kids like i'm
not saying run don't walk but like
make a trip of it one day it's if you
like star wars if you're like
star wars
don't bother i'm not saying it's good
enough to make you like star wars it
could
but if you like star wars [ __ ]
unbelievable you only went three weeks
though that was your first time um yeah
yeah i hadn't been to galaxy's edge we
talked about it pre-pandemic we talked
about like uh we'll take a field trip
we'll all go we'll make a fat man of it
and then the pandemic hit and it shut it
all down and i hadn't been back until
yeah it must have been like three weeks
ago maybe a month ago
um it was great
i bought this so this is a
spirit jersey star wars shirt but look
at this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
nice
all the action figures man oh my god i
saw this
i don't really buy other people's [ __ ]
anymore now i just pretty much wear you
know [ __ ] jay and son of bob [ __ ] all
the time
so i'd wrap myself up and also can't
expect others
to buy a j and sound bob shirt if i'm
not wearing them myself and [ __ ] but
this
i was like oh
i'm i must have her and now this morning
i was actually i loved the shirt so much
i was regretting not buying a second
this will wear out one day i just bought
this shirt and i'm already worried about
the day that it doesn't anymore i'm like
this will wear out one day and i'll
never be able to find it again
um yeah you got to have your uh the
closet full of star wars shirts like
laszlo from real genius just like i just
wear the one thing yeah
i already have that [ __ ] closet
um that's me what you've been up to my
friend um this has been this i guess
since the last time we podcasted
um i got nominated for an eisner award
man
that's right that's your big news man
i'm like i got copen [ __ ]
mark bernard and ladies and gentlemen
what was the last week
yeah yeah yeah last like wednesday i
think
nominated for a eisner award which i
mean most people watching this would
know but in case you're like i don't
know [ __ ] about comics it's the oscars
of [ __ ] comic books
yeah um
for adora and the distance man yeah
i was just gonna say for best
publication for teens i think was the
category
[ __ ] fantastic is there now is it the
do they have
is it like regular like the oscars where
there's like you versus three other
people there's five other people i think
um or maybe four other books in
contention
um
uh some of which i know the people
behind them because comics is a
relatively small industry
and so there's you know some friends
some acquaintances some some former
colleagues
um i i and and i it's i'm sure there's
some version of campaigning for an
eisner um
which feels icky in a weird sort of way
because like hey man like we made the
book the book was the win
you know getting the book out into the
world was was the goal and everything
else on top of that is gravy and when
you work too hard for gravy it starts to
feel weird
um
that said i will 100 encourage people if
they're feeling thinking about voting i
think the deadline is june 7th maybe you
know tell us a vote our way that'd be
nice how do you do it um i think you
have to be um
a registered professional
um with comic-con it's a comic-con award
the san diego comic san diego comic-con
international
is the organization and the eyes news is
a sort of non-profit adjunct to that
and if i remember correctly don't you
quite like myself already have an inkpot
award
i do have an inkpot from yes the was it
2018 2019 or it was in the before times
yeah the before times it was the same
year i remember that
um that we both went it was 2019 i think
it was the the reboot year yeah um and
so yeah if you if you are a person who
makes comics um you've probably been
invited at some point to be an eisner
voter um i was an eisner judge once like
at this point 15 16 years ago
um
you i
judge something i don't believe it mwah
render opinion
so where can they get the book
um the book is now available any place
you buy books if you want it from a
comic book store your local comic shop
can have it or can get it if you want to
go online amazon will have it barnes
noble will have it you know any number
of comic book retailers who do business
online my comics will have it midtown
comics will have it um working with the
good folks at the secret stash
to uh to sell some signed copies
what comic book store is that you say
that would be j7 bob's secret stash in
red bank new jersey oh good lord that'd
be nice yeah that makes sense you should
[ __ ] uh we should get you a box of
books and sign them and [ __ ]
yeah
home for signed mark stuff indeed that
uh that seems to be bless you
that seems to be in the works already um
so when that's when that's live and
ready to rumble we'll uh we'll let good
folks know
you did not think for a second that uh
you were gonna win an eisner award when
you were writing that book did you no
i wasn't even sure the book was ever
going to come out when i was writing
that book i hoped it would
but you know didn't have an artist
another publisher just wrote it to write
it
and now knock on wood i will go to an
award ceremony and uh and maybe come
home with some brass
you're gonna win that award when you do
you stand up there first thing you say
is morbid time
saving bedtime same fat channel
um that is tremendous man absolutely
[ __ ] tremendous yeah that makes me
happy
um and then i i saw some movies
in addition to the tv we will talk about
later on
but um the first movie that i saw i did
not expect to like as much as i did
chippendales rescue rangers
i it looks like uh roger rabbit
it's very roger rabbit it's very like
did i i didn't even know what to expect
signing up for it other people people
like it's really good you should watch
it and so i had a friday night that i
wasn't busy with and 90 minutes to kill
and flipped it on and it is very much
like
chippendale or two chipmunks who met
each other in elementary school and
became friends and then became actors
together and then they had a breakup
because dale wanted to split up and do
his own thing and so chip became an
insurance salesman and dale became an
actor who sort of became a washed-up b
actor who does conventions to make money
and one of their friends from the rescue
rangers gets kidnapped because he has a
stinky cheese addiction much like heroin
and so they've got to go down the trail
to discover who kidnapped um
monterey jack was his name that's
adorable that's adorable um that leads
them onto the trail of a bootlegging
ring
that is just turning uh beloved
characters into off-brand knock-off
versions of themselves
which is how they get to wrap in
south park and shrek and sonic and
all of this ip that disney does not own
um because it's it's not the
legit
like licensed version it's the pirated
version
and so
it's like it's got the bad sonic right
right they sonic with human teeth
and you know they've got the the the
knockoff um like shrek dolls that get
melted to turn into something else it's
it's meta and it's fun but it's also
like just it's a really solid little
[ __ ] movie
i recommend well i i you know i've seen
nothing but
uh kind words and high praise and stuff
so it's only a matter of time before i
get to it but you giving me the nudge
yeah
it's no paddington 2
paddington 2 is legit world-class cinema
this is just everyone says that do you
need see paddington one in order to not
at all is that right yeah i hadn't seen
paddington one before i saw paddington
two
and cried like a [ __ ] baby which is
the hugh grant one two two
two
seriously like if you're if you're in a
mood
and if you're let's say you know in
quarantine for a bit
then yeah just [ __ ] spool up some
paddington and watch the world get rosy
done and done man
then the other movie that i saw
was top gun colon maverick wait a second
you went to the [ __ ] danger zone
went
all the way on the highway to the danger
zone wow man what the [ __ ] um what a
maverick you are i really am
we you get to see it in 40x with our
good friend brett deacon i saw in 40x
first and listen wait
first you saw this first twice two times
two times
all the [ __ ] stuff that you like will
be like i don't like it you saw
top gun two twice that's how good it is
because here's the thing and i told you
this before like that's your lines again
it's my line i'm not sure it's a good
movie um it's very much like a a thin
remake of the first one
which is like here's this school full of
hot shot fighter jocks and then here's
the teach who comes in and humbles them
but here's the mission they have to go
on and they've got to get their [ __ ]
together before they go well there's
your hot shot and there's your kid who's
not ready for it and there's a big loss
in the middle of it that sort of rocks
your hero on his on his hind heels but
then they got to go into some mysterious
foreign place that they don't ever name
they just called the enemy and like do a
mission that of course comes out
victorious
that's top gun one and top gun two both
movies like if i've i i've saw i've not
seen top gun in
[ __ ] over 20 maybe 30 years at this
point but
what you just described sounded an awful
lot like the first topic yes oh and in
the middle there there is a a amateur
sporting event on on sand where
everybody's got no shirts on
are they playing with the boys probably
with girls this time too yes there's a
couple of girls who are wearing sports
bras
playing with the boys and the girls
because
it's two top number two hey
there are lady pilots too this time hey
let me ask um
top gun one
uh the love interest was um
kelly mcgillis
is she referenced
um
no
not even like hey didn't you used to
date the dot dot dot no
no
they don't ever bring her up
but lots of other continuity right like
oh it's nothing but a a movie ultimately
about goose
and the sort of absence of goose and
responsibility over the death of goose
and then how he tried to be a surrogate
dad to gusta's son
played by miles teller is meg ryan in it
mcgregor is not in it but they
referenced that character
that was goose's girlfriend right that
was goose's wife i think at the time
um
but and it's actually like it's
it's a rare sort of thing that i don't
think our parents ever got to experience
which was the feeling of an actor that
you've loved since you were young
who has gotten old with you who's
reconnecting to a character that he
played when he was young
and now gets to carry all of that
baggage of a life with him and you have
also carried all of that baggage of your
life with him you know like they didn't
used to do that like
i'm trying to think of the i mean dirty
harry maybe is the longest version of
the same actor playing the same role
over decades um
but that feeling of nostalgia that
feeling of of we've been through some
[ __ ] together you and i tom cruise and
now here you are at the end of this
particular road
um it's kind of magical it's a bit like
keanu reeves in his current iteration
where it's like we've been watching you
since you were like 15 years old
and now you're an old man killing people
in john wick and that's pretty cool
um
but yeah like tom cruise is doing real
acting which he hasn't done in a while
um there's a beautiful scene with him
and val kilmer which is great
um not to spoil too much but i'm pretty
sure you guys knew
that ice
ice plays a role
um
and the air cinematography [ __ ] is great
like you know as good as it was back in
the 80s with tony scott it's better now
and so who's the uh director
joseph kaczynski
who did oblivion and did tron legacy
um
and uh there was one other movie that i
that's escaping me at the moment
but
who does a fine fine [ __ ] job with
this
you know like it's beautifully done
and
the
like i started like i got somewhat
emotional during the over the course of
the movie for various reasons it was
designed to do that
but the opening logo card
is the two lightning bolts hitting a
tree and it's a don simpson jerry
bruckheimer production
oh my god they went back they went back
and i was like you know what that's
[ __ ] lovely yeah as for those who
don't remember i mean jerry bruckheimer
has been a solo force for so long now
most people probably identify him by
himself but it used to be half of
simpson bruckheimer yeah
and brooke and simpson passed away i
think it was cancer
um
decades ago
and i think the last movie they did
together was
um
the [ __ ] nascar movie
um
days of thunder age of thunder that's it
um in chat fraser lomas says paul newman
kind of did the same thing with the
hustler and color of money which also
tom cruise very true maybe tom cruise
took a page out of paul newman's book he
was like oh yeah maybe one day
yeah yeah
that i think to your point mr chat
person that is the other um
the other one that sort of didn't come
to mind but i think qualifies
if you uh
gave it a letter grade what would you
give
it's a solid b plus
you know and if and if you're in the
right frame of mind maybe an a minus
how was the 40x of it all
it's and not to cast any aspersions on
the 40xs that we've seen in the past
um this is the best version of
it would imagine right because it's
yeah it's very it's very this stuff it's
very that stuff there's like wind that
blows in the theater in your air when
you're in these in these planes there's
heat lamps and heat fans right behind
your ears so when the planes hit the
afterburners suddenly there's heat
coming from behind you i'm like oh
that's a nice touch like well done guys
um
i i honestly cannot recommend this movie
enough
and it's not because it's good minds you
it just it feels all the ways you want
it to feel
is there any of the
other the i'm sure the score is the top
gun for but are any of the songs from
the old top gun and [ __ ] like take my
breath away
um no no that [ __ ] you don't get that
you do get um great balls of fire
in a nice scene um you don't get that
you've lost that loving feeling
but
no call back to that because
great balls of fire is the real
um it's actually a very touching moment
when you hear great balls of fire
um
but the score
um
hans zimmer lady gaga and harold
faltermeier
and even though harold faltimer passed
away they still use that like gong
you know because that score
the og score is very very recognizable
and they're like we can't do a top gun
move without that score and so i think
they just like yep all right we'll loop
in this whole sonic palette and so when
we're like time for the big mission here
comes the old top gun score
i'm sorry i was just looking up harold
faltemart when did he pass
um i thought it was within the last like
five years i think
unless i'm mistaken
i don't think i'm mistaken
still alive
then outstanding job harold falton
conducting from beyond my mental grave
he's uh 69.
um
i worked with him on cop-out i requested
harold tonight who do you want to score
i was like well this is like an 80s cop
movie so like
you think harold faltemeyers
he was such a delightful dude um also
responsible for the fletch score
and beverly hills cop of course beverly
hills cop yeah he was the go-to man
it was mike post who died that i was
thinking of the guy who did every 80s tv
show yeah
he did uh hill street blues
he
[Applause]
yeah
[ __ ] man well we got news to get to kids
beyond this
we've got you know other [ __ ] and we
gotta talk about obi-wan kenobi uh but
uh before we do any of that we gotta pay
some bills man and this week oh
it's gonna be easy to
i mean it's always easy when we have a
proud sponsor fat man beyond this week
is gonna be super easy because it's a
product that i could stick in my mouth
and eat ladies and gentlemen give me a
meat that's right man it's emmy
uh
i-m-m-i i'm gonna send you their website
so you can follow along while we
chit-chat
um if i could just find the website good
lord
it's
emmyeats.com
i-m-m-i-e-a-t-s dot com slash fat man or
use a code famine at checkout to get
five dollars off your first order
uh this emmy is wonderful man uh i've
eaten it lots it's uh
like it's ramen
but it's ramen
that you know it was you know for those
of us who
don't
don't do the animal-based products
plant-based individuals but it's like so
good it's not like oh man you're giving
up something to eat this vegan product
it's tasty you know i know it's good my
kid stole it
from me i had a big box of it because i
bought it for myself and [ __ ] and my kid
took it she's a big ramen fiend and
stuff she was like how is it great and
then before i knew it she'd taken uh six
packages with her
a
true story man
the the the moral of that story is if
you have kids they're gonna take the
food right out of your mouth
like bricks of heroin they're gonna
smuggle your dry ramen out of the house
one moment you're there
when the doctor you know pulls her from
uh from the birth canal you're the first
to see her face and the next minute
she's like give me emmy and she takes
your food
off like i gotta work hard for that she
don't care um emmy is so [ __ ] good
it's worth a family battle kids and uh
the good news is there's always more i
can get more
crunch all you want we'll make more
it's uh it's low carb right like only
six grams of net carbs per serving it
makes it easy to reach your health goals
high protein uh each serving helps you
to stay full longer 21 grams of protein
and it's 100 plant-based and dairy-free
so people like kev can get down on it
yeah man can't can't people like kev get
a [ __ ] break ladies and gentlemen for
once
finally man feel free to add anything uh
in i i like to throw in some chopping on
top of it it's tasty in and of itself
but i like to spice it up a little
tahini as well man
nice
if you're a ramen fan
good lord
even if you're not vegan it's
and you're a ramen fan it's tasty ramen
man
all you have to do kids is go to
emmyeats.com that's i-m-m-i-e-a-t-s
emmy eats dot-com
fat man you get five bucks off your
order
uh that's
emmyeats.comfatman
or just click the link i'm sure
somewhere on the video yeah there it is
probably
um emmy's also proud to offer you a
hundred thousand dollars
ladies and gentlemen emmy
is also proud to offer a 100
happiness guarantee which is just as
good as a hundred thousand dollars
you know what a hundred thousand dollars
guarantees happiness emmy says we'll cut
out the middle man we'll just give you a
hundred percent happiness
uh you can try emmy
free and decide for yourself is if
emmy's worth it man if you're not happy
with your emmy they will offer you a
full refund within 30 days of purchase
are you kidding me
you're kidding me
no
no right there man
emmyeats.com i m i eats all one word dot
com slash fat man uh emmy eats give me
emmy
get some emmy in me
that sounds even sexy
we thank good folks at uh emmymyeats.com
for being a proud sponsor
of this year's show fat man beyond i
mean listen to these numbers man
like
85 lower neck carbs than other instant
ramen brains
three times more protein four times more
fiber
100 plant-based
i i look i'm not good at math but that
all adds up for me
um
and i can vouch for it i actually eat
the [ __ ] so thank you to the good folks
at emmy uh for sponsoring this week's
episode of fat man beyond uh now
uh should we talk about the
star wars show um we can there's we
a we have a [ __ ] ton of trailers to talk
about
and b
there's a star wars show we can talk
about
and then some other news what were the
what are the what's the trailer talk um
well we got and since last we met a new
thor four trailer throw 11 thunder
excellent trailer i'm here for it can't
wait
yeah and the more i save it the more i'm
excited for it
um because this this new version of thor
who is
slightly daffy very dopey and totally
adorable
um
is the version of thor that i'm here for
agreed man um so yes a wonderful trailer
we got to see gore the god butcher for
the first time
um christian proving that
you know uh you either die a hero
long enough to become more the butcher
the god butcher god butcher um russell
crowe is zeus
and you know i saw some people
being like well look at his zeus
compared to zack snyder's zeus i think
the idea is they're taking the piss out
of this zeus like
and to be fair this is the
the russell crowe look at zeus is kind
of more the
traditional
yeah it wasn't like a hard body
my zeus was lawrence olivier who was
definitely not cut
of anything but camembert cheese
stuff
this guy likes to like you know i'm
going to come down as a golden shower
[Laughter]
people want to have sex with a swan and
[ __ ] like that
like if you can shape shift you don't
have to work out
what are the odds that zeus since here
here
there's a character called gore the god
butcher
we have zeus russell crowe
you know
do you think they you think he gets
gourd
uh i i think that's an even money that's
an even money bet
um yeah i'm there for that movie man but
you know i'm there for
almost
um what else did you see trailer was we
had the she-hulk attorney law trailer
uh which i see they updated the cg on a
few shots did they already
yeah that's i've seen conflicting
reports i i
some people have said yes and some
people are like no these are just better
pictures but if you look closely at the
poor work in the first version and the
current version of the trailer like
there there's more
it's starting to look more human like
not just a big green cartoon and stuff
um
i mean look i'm there for it but i
wasn't like oh my god get out of my way
i did read
several wonderful reviews about ms
marvel though
did make me
scramble for my disney plus because i
thought maybe it was up already but it's
not yeah not till next month some
critics got to see it early and stuff
and the early buzz has been like
it's fun and a blast and like everything
like about the you know coming-of-age
superhero story should be
so that was something that i was like
yeah i'll watch it but now i'm like i
want to see that yeah you know i'm i'm
i'm curious about she-hulk you know i
thought i thought the tone of it
was cool i thought it was fun i thought
it was like oh yeah [ __ ] lost
shenanigans and superhero shenanigans
trying to coincide and
with each other then like that's that's
fun i'm here for that bill set in the
world of yeah isn't that kind of i
remember correctly isn't that what john
byrne
or john burton he didn't i necessarily
i've when he did his she-hulk where he
had her talking to the camera breaking
the pork wall and stuff he i remember at
the time referenced moonlighting as his
reference
like he was going this is something they
did on moonlighting um
i think that book goes back that
yeah his version of she-hulk i thought
it was an early 80s early mid 80s book i
think so
um
it looks like or
i would say mid to late 80s book if i
had to remember correctly
um not that i don't want to fight you
mark
i mean we don't have to you're sick
especially i got coveted i'm really weak
but if they do that if they kind of you
know do her talking to camera and stuff
i'd be down like a clown for that um
i mean either way i'm watching it but it
it didn't get
get me as excited as
just reading about the ms marvel series
they uh they did a very good whatever
they did with that show apparently it
translated to a lot of people that
watched it because the
stuff they wrote made me go like i want
to see that immediately but i'm there
for she-hulk absolutely i love
tatiana maslany
yeah
wonderful actress um and also we get
more [ __ ] uh
ruffalo from buffalo man
ain't nothing wrong with that everyone
loves [ __ ] mark ruffalo and he's
playing smart hulk again too i know
i think we're we're always going to be
in the smart hulk world
until or unless they realize that like
you know would be great if he was stupid
again
we got to make them
in the multiverse we get the dumb hoax
again
and then two trailers came out of uh
star wars celebration which is still
ongoing
um but you know first day they gave us
the andor trailer our first look at that
um and the willow trailer for the tv
series extension of willow um i did not
see either of these trailers yet oh well
then we shouldn't talk other than to say
oh you can spoil the hell out of them
they're not neither of them are
if they're shows i'm sure i'll watch but
none that i'm like get out of my way
yeah i mean it's they're both very good
trailers for what seem to be very
different shows and that andor is very
much about you know sort of hard
scrabble formations of rebellion the
prequel to rogue one and it seems to
carry that tone
all the way through um and willow just
looks like a romp i mean willow looks
fun
you know yeah i mean it's it's
it's very much after that kind of ron
howardy you know the light comedy
slash you know daring do of willow um
and you know it's nice to see warwick
davis again man it's not he seems to be
having a good time
um do they reference matt bardigan or
that's just an adventure he had years
ago oh no i you know one of one of the
characters in the show is this daughter
i think of mad martign and whatever her
name was joanne wally killer and
yeah um see now i'm like a thousand
percent
uh i'm just like i the other day i
rewatched watchmen
the hbo series which is [ __ ] sublime
and some incredible [ __ ] writing um
but um
oh [ __ ] i forget why i even referenced
it what were we just talking about
um
uh the
child this the offspring of mad martign
oh
watchman is another one of these like uh
and they had kids and that's who's in
the show like
like degrassi the next generation like
in as much as
angela's the grand
daughter
of
without spoiling a a a hero from the
original
um
and
lady true without spoiling it
is the
kid of one of the main characters there
it's
you know it's
it's a it's a trope that [ __ ] people
love dude
yeah this [ __ ] has now grown up
and they got kids and now they're
the focus of the adventure and [ __ ] yeah
i always think of that as uh
degrassi a lot of people like no man
that's star trek the next generation but
not so much to me star trek next
generation it's not like kirk's son was
on star trek exactly but [ __ ] and
when they did degrassi next generation
was like remember spike
this is that baby she had on the show
that's [ __ ] nuts yeah i will say as
also a slight digression i have been
watching and loving star trek strange
new worlds
can you recommend it for somebody who
only watches the movies um yes
um it does not require
previous knowledge of like deep
knowledge of anything because it's a
prequel to the classic series it's a
prequel to kirk spock and whatever um so
these are adventures that that have
never been charted before that don't
really even need to slip into any
continuity that you're aware of
um
and they're just right it's captain pike
it's captain pike with spock as his
science officer
with a very young cadet uhuru
on the bridge or on the bridge
the security officer i think is
i don't remember how it's relation maybe
it's a cousin or a sister or something
or whatever
but to con noonion sing
um
there is is some relation to that
character is on the bridge um and they i
know they're introducing captain kirk
next season but as like young lieutenant
jim kirk
um who will then in star trek
the pilot is with pike
and then how did they
kirk wasn't in the first in the pilot
right
right i mean the way the the the pike of
it all
for a slight
deep dive detour they shot a
pilot for star trek um with jeffrey
hunter as captain pike
and um
and the network was like well
we don't love it we still want to be in
the star trek business but we think it
could be a little bit lighter we think
it could be way more colorful um so uh
we want you to take another swing at it
and the other swing at it was
the william shatner star trek that we
know of but unwilling to get rid of of
or waste the footage they shot for that
pilot they then refashioned it into like
a a i think middle of season one or
season two episode called the menagerie
where they just use these flashbacks to
that pilot to tell the story of how
captain pike got like crazy wounded and
he's in some kind of wheelchair thing
where he can only only speak with beep
boops and beeps or whatever but all
those flashbacks of the pilot that they
already shot
but
pike had the enterprise before kirk does
and then pike in continuity dies
and
kirk takes over
so is that
is the first episode of star trek
captain kirk taking over
it's just he's already at the bridge
he's already you don't see his like hi
i'm jim
it begins with them right flying around
in space right so like a movie where you
got a show like this is how we got here
right you know which the jj movie does
is like in jj movie like pike is the
captain and then pike gets injured and
he gets captured whatever kirk's gotta
be the man who takes over and so forth
and so on
but it's very episode of the week it's
very just adventure we're doing it we're
meeting a new thing we're going on a
different planet um and a tone is just
lovely and it's fun and it's funny and
it moves
and then it does the thing that star
trek is great at doing and has been
great at doing since the 60s
is sitting down to tell some moral story
or some socially relevant story um
you know the people who are upset that
suddenly star trek is woke clearly have
never seen star trek because it was all
about race and class
and homelessness and social ills and
violence and all of it
and so it is continuing on that threat
in a sort of lovely way
um
can't recommend it highly enough if you
got to watch one star trek show just to
pick up one and go um right now i would
do strange new worlds but to that point
like you get your spock on it you get
your your child or offspring or
um relation to a classic star trek
villain you get your
you know characters who you know will
grow up and become legends and then you
get yours that you know at some point
will die um it's nice that way
you watching barry on hbo i've never
seen an episode of barry let me tell you
something don't sleep on that show it's
really [ __ ] good that being said
bill hader is a wonderful
actor [ __ ] does great impressions
he's killer on saturday live
unbelievably talented
his true
[ __ ] gift may be in direction yeah
his directing his episodes stick out
like sore thumbs in the best way because
they are brilliantly composed and
directed this is a guy with an eye and
then
i was thinking about it
before he was bill hader on snl i
believe he was bill hader editor
and so if you're an editor you're a
[ __ ] shooter like you know about
pacing and you watch a lot of stuff and
you
acquire in a massive style by being like
i would do this i wouldn't do that
every episode he directs
is is incredibly special
visually
tonally pace-wise just
dude's gonna my prediction is that
dude's gonna win an oscar one day
ooh
it's redirecting
put some money on it
i will
look just not right now
um
i don't got it
um
um i think that's that's
that's it
those are the trailers those are the
movies that i've seen
um
we could get into the star wars at all
there was quite a bit of star wars news
um not just a celebration but vanity
fair
had a big ass cover story about
the future of star wars being on
television
um and then we got obi-wan
the future of star wars being on
television yeah that was
the uh
the star wars cover line on the vanity
fair was the rebellion will be televised
um and basically talking about both the
the the star wars that we're getting and
how tv seems to have been the saving
grace for a star wars that was flagging
at the box office a bit
um
you know as well as a bit of a check-in
on the movies that we thought we were
gonna get
with no mention of the ones that we know
we're not going to get
um
so
the idea that patty jenkins is rogue
squadron is still kind of in the in the
distance
a thing that you know seems to still be
in progress but not on a front burner um
same thing with the the kevin feige star
wars movie
slash trilogy because i think they were
handing out trilogies like lollipops at
one point um is still in the works taika
waititi's um star wars movie is probably
up next
on deck for them
um but for a franchise that had existed
entirely on
on the big screen
to have seated so much of it to the
small screen was the crux of the story
peg two of course obi-wan coming ahsoka
in production
uh mandalorian season three coming out
um
you know that that's the the thing that
they're
that they seem to be currently hanging
their hat on
um
in chat
there's a bunch of people who are
telling me that bill hader came to
hollywood
to become a director
before the snl stuff
and he was i said he was a cutter
apparently he came out here
to be a director uh [ __ ] it shows
a lot of people are saying he's a film
nerd
uh
t-train says bill hader is amazing he's
straight up a film nerd he loves what he
does so much it's [ __ ]
absolutely clear like
it's not that shows not his episodes are
not directed like
uh all right
we got it we're moving on like this is a
guy who has a vision
um
yeah it's [ __ ] good this is a totally
good watch
um anyway
shall we uh
dive into obi-wan let's do it
um
let me tell you something about this
obi-wan boy they kept it real quiet what
the show is going to be about have you
watched both episodes yeah
i was i'm glad they kept that quiet um
the the
kids we're gonna spoil obi-wan so if you
haven't watched it yet
um it'd be ob wonderful if you [ __ ]
do this or something like that so you
don't get mad when we spoil it
um spoilers beginning do we have one of
those bars to put up say spoiler
will just count them in
five four
three
two one
spoilers abound kids uh when you watch
the you know the trailer we all got
excited because like look at baby luke
oh my god it's gonna be about him
taking care of little baby luke you know
this could be nuts
did not think for a [ __ ] second
that it was gonna be
what it is i i really hesitate in
wanting and giving out the information
maybe we'll see how i don't know if we
could talk about it without talking yeah
i mean i i think at some point we'll
have to because
um
spoiler alert
i quite liked it like i i really liked
it um
but
my problem with it is
ah
yeah there's there's a thing
um
is just
it's about that character that we're not
talking about yet
um
because there's a couple of scenes
like
there's and i think it's one in the
first episode one in the second episode
where there's a chase
where actual grown people
need to check down a 10 year old and
fail at it
miserably
twice and this 10 year old is not like
[ __ ] wally west is not like i'm a
speed demon
i'm a kid who can't run very well
and so the keystone copsiness of that
stuff
just didn't quite work for me
as well as the like
i'm a very smart precocious young child
who we've established is smart and it's
established who sort of knows things
beyond her years
but sorry did i already spoil it with
her anyway um after a child is kidnapped
and then rescued by obi-wan
starts doing dumb child [ __ ]
even though she should know
that the situation is dire the danger is
the the danger is grave she said grave
danger is there any other kind i said
there's no other kind
and someone is like i don't trust you i
don't believe that oh can i get
something to eat oh i want to buy
shopping like
listen girl you know what's going on
here
um so it was just the
i know you want to have the foil between
obi-wan and this kid and you want that
little clash and attention but there's a
way to make
kids be troublesome without making them
stupid and i feel like this fell into
the we're making a stupid kid trap
predictions in terms of their
relationship
she's only ever gonna know him as ben
right
um no because what's his face um
um
[Music]
because there's canon that we have to
hit eventually
yes
but that cannon
there was never any mention about and by
the way
one time you went chasing me around this
planet remember like
well i mean there's the things that
that's my prediction my prediction is he
will be ben the whole time
and she will never find out
that he is the same person who
you know a decade hence she'll be
calling out for hope to help help too
how are we supposed to do this without
[ __ ] spoiling it i mean you know we
we can
i think
yeah
um
i mean we've already worn the spoil
yeah
um
that that was part of the fun for me as
i was sitting there going
wow i hadn't thought about this never
imagined doing this
even though they showed us
you know something in the trailer which
if you do the mental math you're like
well there is another
like never once occurred to me they were
gonna
try it
um and then when i saw the direction you
know i was when they first
took us
to that planet
and
i even before it happened i think my
wife was like oh it's gonna be and i was
like no
and then it was and i was like oh my
lord uh
what what a delightful
choice
um you know
because i was concerned that we were
gonna have another show where we're
hanging out on tatooine for eight
episodes or six episodes or whatever it
is
like i don't really need to be here
again i've just spent like five years on
this [ __ ] planet
and the fact that suddenly it's ooh is
this
is this alderaan have we never really
seen alderaan before
this is cool
and then we're on like the neo-tokyo
planet whatever they keep on calling in
his name that escapes me but it's always
dark and it's always led by neon it's
always a sound stage yes it's always the
volume
it's that it's i'm not i ain't taking
anything away i enjoy the show but those
shots
in that
their use of the volume
is great it looks deep but the floor
looks like
a
floor
but you know what i'm saying it just
looks like oh we're on sound stage for
sure
um but yeah to aid to have that
different visual palette you know and
like i gotta say it man
it is it is a world of difference for me
i mean i came around on the mandalorian
but i remember the very beginning of
that show i was like i can't i don't see
how a main character whoever takes his
mask off we're supposed to form any real
attachment to
um and it turns out we formed attachment
because grogu was attached to him and
that was our way into giving a [ __ ]
about mando was grogu gave a [ __ ] about
mando but to have
an actor
with eyes who look at us who feel some
[ __ ] on his face and for that actor to
be you and [ __ ] mcgregor who was just
doing all of this like deep emotional
work of
like be draggled and haunted and
you know just just the feeling that he's
an abject failure in the world for
having lost everything
and just seeing him work his shitty you
know hacking up a
a crate dragon or whatever the [ __ ] that
is you know day in day out slicing up a
sand whale
smelling like [ __ ] like all of that
stuff
on his face
and then surrounding him with other
great actors i mean you get [ __ ] you
know joel edgerton you get
um
all of the inquisitors i mean they're
all great like
it and and kumail nanjiani even as a
like comic relief
you know a would-be jedi all that [ __ ]
is so great but you and mcgregor are the
center of this is a thing that none of
these shows have had and i think it
helps immensely that he's there
um freddie nunez in chat said kevin
remember help me obi-wan kenobi you're
my only hope
i do remember that
uh she will know his name and this
adventure is what leads her to send that
message i disagree
because never once in that message does
she say
we've met she she is sending a message
to a guy she has never met and she sang
years ago you fought with my father you
served my father well during the clone
wars yes so
she has the only way this all works is
if
she thinks this guy's name is ben
because in you know in star wars the
name ben kenobi and obi-wan kenobi are
like clark kent and superman
like one is a pair of glasses to
separate the [ __ ] two you know like
nobody's like wait a second i wonder if
this obi-wan kenobi you're looking for
is old ben kenobi
well i mean but to be fair kumao
nanjiani calls him obi-wan and she's
there
um
the third sister the inquisitor who's
chasing after him is shouting obi-wan
throughout that entire cargo bay
i think i'll be mad if
if they that that's that's where i bump
into it i was because when i saw it i'm
like well this is
dangerous
this is a dangerous territory like i i
just read that they're like we're moving
away from the skywalker saga and it's
like but not yet
i mean the minute the show is called
obi-wan kenobi like we're still in it to
be fair like you know maybe this is one
of their last bites at the apple if they
are serious about like we're moving on
in star wars from here on in it ain't
gonna be about skywalkers
this is like one of your last
opportunities
you mean you could do whatever you want
but
if they're if their manifest is to move
forward
this is one of your last shots to like
hey man like what other nostalgia can we
pick at and
they picked the right one as i was
sitting there and i realized what they
were doing i was like wow good for you
that's great like
i thought it was going to be this and
it's this and
i'm delighted by this that being said
uh yeah you know
there were there were a few like
him you you and mcgregor like whoa like
home alone missing the kid
yeah
and this is a guy who killed darth maul
yeah the the the and especially the
first one in the [ __ ] you know the
forest of alderaan
where flea is chasing a kid with his you
know bad henchmen guys it's like within
something right wasn't he in one of the
movies already i don't know i don't know
the flea i think he was a call back if i
remember correctly
but like maybe not i'm thinking of him
from back to the future
maybe that's what the fallback is yeah
but like that chase on that forest did
not need to be in this show like once
you look at it and see how bad it it was
and how bad it was realized
all you needed is flea cornering her in
the forest and then putting a bag on her
head and you're done like i don't
necessarily need the [ __ ] like
walking on this and ducking under the
vat and fleeing his guys going oh
we just missed this child who can't run
or get a [ __ ] stunt double guys
like
uh speaking of sun doubles uh riva there
is about five minutes where she was just
running on walls and running across
rooftops and not much was going on there
no
no not really a hell of an opening to
that show though uh with the order
order 66 six and like
killing younglings and stuff like i'm
like oh [ __ ] like they're taking us back
there
what i was hoping would happen you know
and maybe they'll do it they still have
five more episodes to go because i think
it's just six
is that riva was one of those kids
who was you know being trained by the
jedi
and you know chased because of all that
[ __ ] and fell in with the empire that
way and so just just to tie it to the
main show as opposed to just you know a
thing that happened once
um or to show anakin you know
doing the [ __ ] cutting down of kids
again um
but still yeah order 66 is always a
[ __ ] metal way to open a show
um
i'm uh
uh i'm in
yeah
yeah because it happens every time any
saftey is that who i saw is it
yeah as the tatooine jedi who
who gets [ __ ]
hung up yeah yeah
like not hung because there's nothing
around his neck so it's very like you
know
pg violence yeah but i mean but
suspended huh not like
yeah it looked like his body's on
display like on a trader's gate kind of
thing
um that guy the bald guy uh spoilers he
lasted pretty long
yeah
yeah i i didn't expect that to happen so
quickly yeah i went pretty good how many
episodes is this
six yeah
so we're
a third through already yeah
and the second episode was short the
second episode was like 38 minutes long
it was a quick burn
um i admire what they did in terms of
like i i didn't see it coming and and uh
you know i'm
i'm into this ride but it it just has to
has to
end up right
well you know
i think it was it might have been like i
was sitting there going like
they never meet
in star wars
she is being you know they're rushing to
get to the plane
the plane
it's a plane it's a plane trying to
catch a delta off that
they're trying to get to the millennium
falcon and uh that you know luke sees
then well obi-wan fighting darth vader
and he's like ben
um so she never encounters him in the
whole movie does she
no except i mean no she doesn't but she
does say when luke says i'm here obi-wan
kenobi's with me she's like obi-wan's
with you
great but she never sees him she never
sees him
and he never he's never like
hey man remember when you ran away from
me on that [ __ ] nutty when i bought
you gloves remember that
gloves
because you're a rebel daddy why didn't
you reference that in your message
i worked for your dad what the hell is
this
um
but i i think it was like lenween or
marv wolfman one of those other classic
comic book writers who was like
continuity is your friend until it's
your enemy and then you ignore it to
tell a better story
um
and so the idea that they're just gonna
be like you know what this is what i
wanted to tell if it doesn't dovetail
perfectly
so what
uh raul espinoza says the bald got a
bold guy i said ball guy he might have
spelled it wrong the grand inquisitor is
not dead he says
okay
i mean
he looked dead he sure looked dead to me
yeah
but he didn't take a i i'm not crazy he
took a lightsaber to the gut right yeah
yeah or the chest dropped him and he
didn't stop him you stopped moving i'm
not saying this person's wrong i'm just
saying i just want to make sure that i
saw what you saw
indeed um i'll be honest with you man i
wasn't like
when they announced this i was like oh
all right
like i wasn't like oh man get out of my
way [ __ ] obi-wan kenobi
but i'm i'm actually more interested in
it now but i know what it is then i have
been
with them talking about it for the
better part of a year or whatever
yeah i was just i was always in because
i'm just such a young mcgregor fan
and you know despite
all of what the prequels were and i'm
also completely mindful there's an
entire generation for whom that's their
star wars and they love it dearly the
way i love the classic trilogy and the
way i don't know zygotes love the sequel
trilogy
but
obi-wan for me was the redeeming factor
of those movies
um i just loved his performance
and his commitment to it
uh dipsy doing chad is screaming at me
in caps she names her son after ben
kenobi yeah no [ __ ]
what's your point
[Laughter]
stop yelling at me
good god um okay
um and people are pointing out the grand
inquisitor is a main character in star
wars rebels he will be fine he's got
plot armor that's hysterical
plot armor that's good
um all right so yeah two episodes of
obi-wan kenobi are up on disney plus
kids and definitely worth a watch and
i'm sure you if you didn't
we tried not to spoil it but i think you
probably got the gist of
yeah yeah i mean we said the name i
think
i think
um
but yes
i think i i was happy with what and i
thought
who is a deborah chow show yeah
great job yeah
very well directed like
she's got a feel like i didn't know
detective jedi was the thing that i
wanted nearly as much as i do
but like watching him just [ __ ] land
on this planet and do the like the three
or four beats worth of detectiveness
and skulking in the shadows and doing
some cool [ __ ] martial arts [ __ ]
without resorting to being a jedi that's
awesome they like i don't know if i can
summon the force anymore because i
haven't done it for a decade moment
where you knew he was going to make her
float even though like can he do it can
he do it i did of course he did it
and i appreciate the restraint of i am
100 sure we're going to see liam neeson
in the show
that's what i said to jennifer i was
like if he says qui-gon
there's no way that by the last episode
[ __ ]
of course it goes because you don't
introduce a gun unless you're gonna
[ __ ] fire it so moment he was like
well [ __ ] even before that when they did
the previously on star wars three
[Laughter]
i appreciate it i was like oh my god
this is fun this is like as if they were
tv shows and they were episodic i guess
but um yeah in the uh
in the previously of it all
they they indicated
yeah it's like i'll teach you how to
commune with uh with your master qui-gon
like by putting him in that
yep
right away i was like hmm yeah literally
obi says i'm gonna teach you how to do
that you're like well then we're gonna
see him do that it's not like it's
without precedent like didn't qui-gon he
was a voice in jj's uh
rise of skywalker so yeah i mean he did
a voice in in in uh clone wars i think
did he really
play
yeah bygone rather
allegedly no he said it oh he said
um
all right
shall we get into the news let's get
into the news kids mark's a news man and
there's gotta be news to get into
because it's been weeks since we've done
this so without further ado's
mark give us the news
the news
um
yeah so
just tapping finally the putting a
lid on the keg of star wars um
ooh last question yes we're gonna see
qui-gon no doubt no doubt do we see the
big chicken guy
who runs the garage
[Laughter]
because they seem very friendly remember
he's like hey if i get more buds and
[ __ ] can't they check in with the big
chicken guy
oh hey no trouble in my bar
he was a fry cook he was like oh this
comes from a
bounty hunter i forget what that dude's
name is but
yeah in the
yeah wherever the [ __ ] that was and the
weird railroad car diner that was in the
belly of coruscant
um
i would love it if we saw him i gotta
say daxter there it is chat decks
nick uh
what's your name nick
god damn it's gone too fast i can't get
you back oh hello dicks
piccolo
that's it can't we get some [ __ ]
decks jetser
dex jetzer uh um you know i was very
proud i noticed uh right away when
obi-wan had that
triangular-shaped ship even before
you know it was a ship i was like that
is the ship that luke skywalker plays
with in his garage
in star wars and she was like ooh you're
very good at this i was like i know what
easter eggs to look out for yeah the big
divorced dad energy off of uh
i bought the kid a toy he's never going
to play with that toy
[ __ ] your toy dad
though uncle owen is a real like hard
ass and [ __ ]
um the boy must be trained like you
trained his father
burn
owen
you know what i'm gonna leave you in the
boy alone go off and have an adventure
with the girl how about that
yeah tell me a bit about your boy now
it's gonna be about the girl there [ __ ]
you he's he's got a sister why don't you
go [ __ ] her up that's what i'm going to
do owen just
if i could catch her she's just
she's the slipperiest slowest child i've
ever met would he notice that she was
force sensitive
i mean he should
if not
the worst jedi
well
clearly
you know he's a big failure after
another big thing exactly heard himself
he's like we the war's over man we lost
um all right
so yes news uh john watts is uh is doing
he
begged off of fantastic four
um to instead do a star wars series that
would be called star wars skeleton crew
with jude law set to star in it
um
it is described in the tone of the
classic amblin coming of age adventure
movie in the 80s about four kids sort of
on the run who stood steal a spaceship
and get involved in all kinds of [ __ ]
star wars related shenanigans what's it
called
skeleton crew
um jew law will probably not be playing
one of the children
and uh well he could because he's that
good he's that good of an actor um but
it sounds like less a skywalker
adventure and more a
let's uh
let's let's expand the universe a little
bit shall we just let's see what these
kids are up to so it feels a bit
stranger things plus the force
that's what it is
that's um
i tell you i i understand the whole we
got to move away from skywalker but like
[Music]
it's gonna be tough
i mean it shouldn't be
but
i i think it just requires commitment
like the people who write the bible go
and print bibles going like we're gonna
move away from the jesus story
i think we've
taken it as far as we can like
i mean not for nothing but the whole
first book is not a jesus story and that
is a pretty good book
that one's the prequel it's metal as
[ __ ] yeah a lot of weird stuff going on
with [ __ ] whales eating men alive and
[ __ ] hell yeah floods fires towers of
salt [ __ ] the angel of death man in a
minute
blood on the [ __ ]
door
door jams and [ __ ] the
death of the firstborn
[Laughter]
[ __ ] [ __ ] sounds so it sounds like we're
in a writer's room trying to come up
with another season of masters of the
universe
this is literally catholic belief says
system
[Music]
we're not making up anything new yeah
this is stuff i was raised to believe in
it's like what if you took christianity
and made it [ __ ] crimson no it
started crimson
that's true crimson and then
christianity kind of cleaned it up a
little bit just like mellowed out a
little bit it's like you're very aggro
in your youth i know i'll get over this
[ __ ] yeah he's like i'm sorry did you
say we cleaned it up again a bit our
symbol
is a man hung on a cross
they're like
but for love though
they're like that's still a pretty
bracing image
listen i can't you can't just make a dog
a fish the whole time like we're still
gonna be
murdery and stabby like this is in terms
of a religious figure like you know
obviously ignore the movie head but
buddha
you know he's just a dude sitting there
and stuff and if it wasn't a cow head
and it was like a buddha head he'd be
smiling and it's very inviting
a crucifix with a man on it like not
when it's just the cross is one thing
but when they've got the
actual body of yeah when the action
figure is there we want to talk about
like
you know a bunch of people being injured
to a horrifying sight
i also appreciate that in these last
five minutes i'm sure it's is not like
for the christians out there like [ __ ]
you i'm talking about the sight of a
human being
hung and dying slowly over a period of
time
is a bracing image if they if you show
they showed that on the news they
wouldn't even show it on the news and
stuff yet some people wear it on
yeah i mean listen i'm heathen so i feel
okay about this but i'm sure there are
people who like listen i was on board
with the mark stuff i even didn't mind
when he hated the [ __ ] that i loved but
he just went too far
he made
he he went too hard
on my god
i don't think we went very hard it's
just
patient it really just is
um so yes we will get not one but two
kid related star wars shows there's star
wars the young jedi adventures which
will be coming on disney plus and disney
junior in spring of 2023.
oh
there he is
when i prefer right there
look at him he's in a good mood
wow
i'm just reading
wow
i thought you were actually impressed
i was doing what it told me to do told
me to wow i wow
um so yeah we got we got more disney
star wars stuff coming down the pike
more movies are happening
apparently the big problem with solo was
that um
you can't recast
legacy characters according to kathleen
kennedy
um
which seems like i think if they had
done that today as a disney plus series
people be like all right they just
recast
kinda a legacy character you know a
young version of that character but
isn't that what solo was a young version
of that
a character i mean also
[ __ ] there's an obi-wan kenobi show
that doesn't have alec guinness in it
that's the other thing as you're
watching this show you just gotta
remember in ten years he goes from euro
mcgregor to [ __ ] full-blown alec
guinness
i mean but also like alec guinness might
have been 60 years old
at the time they shot star wars
62 62-63 those are hard [ __ ] years
the man had lived through a war
yeah he was one of them old-timey
old-timers yeah
we actually saw some [ __ ] in my day
where like jared leto is 52 years old
and that [ __ ] looked he looks
30.
is he 52 he's older
i think he is yeah
i mean then again i also said harold
faltermeyer was alive but
i don't know about you
today he looks like a boy
like a teenage boy he's [ __ ] 52.
um
i'm sorry 50.
december 26 196. it's [ __ ] yeah you
know what i've never thought i'd say
this but it just might be it might be
morbid time
[Laughter]
i appreciate the commitment to a bit
i was reading on twitter this morning a
bunch of people were like
you know in three
they're gonna make a sequel and [ __ ]
jared leto's gonna look at the camera
and say it's morbid time
they're like don't like everything
they're like everything we create gets
taken and they were point they pointed
out
um
uh
bad sonic you know
very sonic they're like now scary
sonic's [ __ ] cool yeah
um but yeah so so that was the lesson
that uh that kathy kennedy took from
solo
is don't recast anybody
yeah i don't
i don't know if that's the lesson i
would have taken from solo i think the
lesson i would have taken from solo is
don't make a movie
twice
isn't that the one where they made a
whole version with lord miller and lord
they did like apparently they shot 70
percent of the lord
and all of a sudden they were like ah
let's do this all over again yeah maybe
that's the
lesson more so than like
don't recast legacy characters
yeah
i think there's a lot of lessons to be
taken from solo um some of it is like
it's big universe they can keep it
making
they don't even have to touch those
characters man no
no they don't you know but i think that
you know we've talked about it before in
the podcast i've talked about it before
in public
i feel like reinterpretation of
characters that are beloved
is necessary for those characters to
survive past a generation or two um
there has to be the version of
james bond of bruce wayne of sherlock
holmes of
superman of whomever captain kirk
that exists beyond the original
interpretation of it so that it becomes
each subsequent generations version of
that character
like we will see somebody else play
indiana jones at some point because
disney's not going to not let that
character exist
for the next 100 years
and so yeah we saw still you know
harrison ford was at celebration they
talked about the new movie talked about
john williams and that's great i'm happy
to see him back
but for that character to disappear
whenever it is that the apparently
unkillable harrison ford passes away
um
doesn't feel fair to audiences doesn't
feel fair to the character
um and probably doesn't jive with the
walt disney's corporate mandate of let's
make money off of our investment of
buying lucasfilm
um
so like everything gets reinterpreted if
it's gonna last it has to be
so just find the right way to do it and
give it the time that it needs i mean we
had just seen
harrison ford's han solo
in force awakens and then like two years
later here's a new guy playing the same
character it's like hey i need some
space man
give me some distance that might have
helped
truth man
why don't you text your buddy kathy
kennedy and tell her these things
kathy
here's what's up
it's me it's it's me the shouty guy on
the internet
who doesn't like any of the things you
make what's the what's the
what what's the first half of let
[ __ ] know i'm be humble but
like [ __ ] now happy it's mark
i'm being humble but i'm letting
[ __ ]
come on now
you know i love you the only problem is
too much solo in one year
yeah i mean it's honestly it's it's it's
beginning to be my feeling about marvel
is that we're getting too much of it and
i never thought that that would be a
problem especially when we began this
journey 12 years ago
but like we were we were at one movie a
year maybe two movies a year then you
get a giant climactic collection of
characters
and now there's like not a month that
goes by where there's not some new
marvel thing happening and
it's almost as if
we don't get a chance to want it anymore
it just keeps coming
what you're saying don't [ __ ] with the
only good thing
that we got going man
i got [ __ ] covet i got this stupid
disease that should have been gone a
long time this virus and i [ __ ] got
it the only thing that makes it all good
is those marvel movies
i said when i got covered i was like oh
man
now i have to live through this because
i desperately want to [ __ ] see
it's a secret invasion
do you know
i really do
what's the next big movie after thor
um
i think it's ant-man
yeah man [ __ ] and we get to see kang
oh see there's so many good reasons to
live yeah there's ant-man and then
there's um
guardians three
another [ __ ] reason to stick around
and then i don't remember what it was i
see did i see they're talking about
perhaps doing a nova movie
really
i saw a title treatment for no will
shaken and said well
uh will is standing in for banff man
today because bamf bam jc is at star
wars celebration limited
and stuff uh can you pop in well there
you go yeah so you know in your head
yeah see well you know if i'm if i'm
gonna be occupying rarefied air i'm
gonna make the most of it
for those who are like what the this is
your discount banff man for tonight yes
discount
when you when you need a ban off wish
here i am
um you were nodding your head off camera
am i right is there a nova
yeah that was one of the things
when did that get announced i that's
come up just i think in the last two
months
but i don't think they've done any
official announcement we'd just like
that insider say there's exploration
about
a nova title
i'm ready
yeah and i forgot about black panther in
november
what do you mean
what i when i said what's next i was
like well eleven thunder and then comes
quantum mania and
this year
what kind of forever is still on the
schedule for november 11th 2022.
my god man so i'll be done with like
clerk's three tour
which by the way i saw a trailer
oh
really can i can i uh
spoilers i mean you made the trailer
shut up so are you in the trailer i was
like holy [ __ ] mark's the lit
um
it didn't get a line in the trailer
no
we could not manifest words
quite work that way um it is uh
you know as a guy who's been watching
like trailers for movies i've made for
nearly 30 years at this point
um i generally always have like great
buddy for my notes i had like i had one
note without changing a shot just
because i thought it was like
too jarring uh but other than that what
a great [ __ ] cut completely
it's an art form like cutting a trailer
like you know making a movie
doesn't necessarily mean you could cut a
good trailer of your movie sometimes
you're too close to it sometimes you
need outside
eyes um and boy oh boy the bond i think
it was lionsgate and the folks at bond
creative
cut a [ __ ] wonderful trailer so um
i i can't wait to share it it's gonna be
a minute uh before that happened i mean
i wonder if that's the sort of thing
where you know between us girls
that a person who had let's say
a whole age panel
at a certain comic book convention
happening in the third week of july
seems like it might be a relatively
decent place
to reveal that to uh to a populist
could be
uh tell you what man
if uh somebody comes out to see me at
hall h uh this summer san diego comic
con which i presume would be on a
saturday night
i'm gonna show them the first like five
minutes of the movie
that's right
nice
[Laughter]
um yeah no we've been talking about it
about uh all the stuff that we're gonna
be doing at uh comic con here's a
preview for you kids at home so nothing
locked in concrete but this is what
we've been working on um we're taking
over uh the tin roof
san diego
uh which is we just did the tin roof in
orlando for the movies pop-up uh we're
taking over tin roof in san diego for
all of comic-con it's gonna be a movies
all day long and then at night it's
movies after dark and we're just going
to do shows there so we'll be doing
hollywood babylon batman beyond jay and
solomon bob get old as nightly shows but
if you've got the time
we've got the beard no you've got the
mark
every night at four or five what i'm
proposing is we do
a one-hour fat man
streaming update where we just do the
news of the con that day
oh
and kind of like
feed the folks at home who don't get to
go and stuff and then we would have our
live show either thursday friday
saturday or something like that at night
um
yeah i mean i'm i'm i'm here for that
um i will be there
so far as looking like the whole time
um i would uh the only the only thing i
know i have to do is i have to go to the
eyes news on friday night
um other than that i'm wide open that's
right you gotta go pick up your award
for evans i'm gonna go get my [ __ ]
brass give it to me
you got the arm full like [ __ ] baby
face at the grammys
um
just do me a favor go up and interrupt
other people when they
just kanye mall yeah i'm gonna let you
finish but
uh
but brian k vaughn had the best comic
book of the year
bounce off
like i saw that dude on
seth myers a few months ago he seemed
much nicer than that he got angry yeah
boy that meyer's [ __ ] went right to his
head
this is all about him
um what other news we got wither of the
news with the news there's a new
daredevil series
that seems to be moving forward at the
disney plus i saw that man so um
uh i mean i guess it can't help but be
his
sequel series it's all connected right
it's all connected you know charlie cox
will be reprising his role as kevin
feige had alluded you know at least two
years ago
saying that when daredevil does return
to the to the marvel universe he will be
played by charlie cox
you think they referenced the events of
the
previous series
um
maybe or select parts of it whatever
they
whatever they would like to acknowledge
as as you know going forward continuity
which you know ultimately is how much we
want to ever talk about iron fist ever
again and i don't know if that
the capacity or the desire for that the
appetite for that is particularly high
um
but you know vincent d'onofrio has also
been you know daredevil and i'm sorry
has been kingpin in a bunch of other
marvel stuff
and so
i see no reason why there's not a
version of barenthal as the punisher
or mike coulter as as luke cage
or uh or jessica ritter as um
i'm sorry kristen kirsten kristen
kristen ritter
as uh jessica jones um
i think there's some version or
even getting those actors back and sort
of help reconstituting that version
of the the mcu
but
who are the show runners uh two fellas
named matt corman and chris ord have
been attached to wright and executive
produce and they did uh covert affairs
on usa together
um as well as the enemy within and the
brave and a cw series called containment
that's fairly recent yeah
yeah yeah
um but yeah they are i mean there's no
dates that involved at all like i think
they're just getting to work on it
whether they even have a writer's room
together or not who knows but it's you
know
marvel is a secret fortress of
information and the fact that that much
slipped out
is itself
somewhat astonishing
sixto reynoso in chat says can we talk
about the rumor that jon hamm is playing
fletch in the reboot i don't think
that's a rumor i think there's a trailer
out no
i didn't i didn't see a trailer i sure
would like to but well i think i think
he
knows that yeah
he was caused
it's like
is making i think confess fletch
um or what one of the fletch books but
it is john hamm who is an excellent
piece of casting for fletch if you know
the books
because he's always meant to be like
like crazy handsome everyone wants to
[ __ ] this guy
and that's
[ __ ] johnny him isn't he he's the
jack reacher of aimless detectives
everybody wants to [ __ ] that guy
reacher said nothing
um uh
christina b said just started what have
they talked about so far in chat oh
christina
we've talked about so many things mike
um eisner nomination top gun two
ben kenobi versus obi-wan kenobi versus
chip and dale
so many things
we're just doing the news
yes we've just been shooting this [ __ ]
for the last two hours
um jj abrams is prepping a new speed
racer show for apple plus apple tv plus
for apple plus for apple apple tv
doesn't have a warner brothers dude um
it's warner brothers tv is the is the
studio bad robot's a production company
but the network is apple
and not hbo max making something for
them
indeed you know and there was a big
article and i want to say was deadline
i'm talking about that uh the new bosses
at warner brothers discovery
are beginning to re-examine all of the
existing businesses that they've got
under their umbrella and seeing how they
can shave and
and sort of reconfigure and and
in certain cases kill
um
projects that have been you know sort of
floating or loitering or too damn
expensive
and one of the things that they were
talking about was the bad robot deal
that that jj and his production company
have at warner brothers
order of a billion dollar deal if i
remember correctly yeah it's a lot of
money for
million but the show that he wants to
make i read is like 200 million yeah
demi monde which i think he's been
working on for over four years yeah
nobody knows what it's about right it's
yeah it's one of those like i mean
better robot is
mystery boxes yeah they're about as
secretive as
as a marvel is
um but in the same initiative of like
looking to
begin to consolidate a little bit warner
brothers killed that uh wonder twin
movies we talked about a couple weeks
back
they're like too expensive don't know
who wants it don't know who it's for um
so as soon as they had announced it into
the world it
got put out of its misery i think that
was an astute decision
i see no fault in it i'm not saying it
couldn't have worked and maybe it would
have been like a fun movie but
it's not a movie that anyone's like i
want that to happen it's like of all the
treasure trove of characters you got you
know you could probably
spend your money a little better yeah
yeah
no i don't i never read a script i don't
know the director was i don't even know
the talent attached was but
just as somebody who's grown up with
this [ __ ] like the wonder twins movie i
didn't never once heard anybody be like
you know it would be amazing
yeah you know
but i never heard anybody say you know
it would be amazing a lego movie
if they had i would have been like why
and yet the lego movie is one of the
greatest movies ever made right but you
could also say
lego is an internationally known
incredibly popular piece of
branding slash ip whatever
um
but according there's a new mandate at
warner discovery that dc movies should
now be made with a theatrical first goal
and wonder twins the way it had been
conceived was too niche said one source
so if that's the case do you think
batgirl is still gonna be an hbo max
thing or do you think they go theatrical
with it first um i'm not sure i mean
some of that is like it's already in a
can so like they it's not a thing they
can cancel now but they might look at
him like you know what yeah [ __ ] it
people know who batgirl is the movie's
pretty good let's put in theaters first
um you know and i think that the the
rationale is look how well the batman
has done for hbo max
you know like a big-ass theatrical hit
can then help drive people to the
service which
sure and also to be fair the pandemic
year's decision to release all
everything
you know day and date also did very well
for the service but
you know and i think that the cost the
price point of the wonder twins movie
was too high apparently it was a 75
million dollar budget but according to
sources um they want to keep hbo max
original movies 35 million dollars in
under
um
and so art smart michael vanderham in
chat said wonder twins would be would
work in a shazam movie give this guy a
[ __ ] job
at warner brother that's a great idea
you don't need to have a whole ass movie
for the wonder twins stick them in like
a shazam picture if people like them
then you'll give them their own movie
yeah there i solved hollywood mark can
we go home
i mean one of us is home already you can
just
turn it off
um but yes so back to the beginning jj
is doing a speed racer show for apple
plus it's going to be live action
um and the original source material is
going back to the to the 60s the classic
manga series but they're not going to
look
like the washowski's movie um it does
not seem as if that that is going to be
one of their reference points
resting movies ever made
it's gorgeous yeah you don't have to
like that movie to be like good god this
is
this is everything a movie
could and should be
something you can't see in the real
world
yet familiar one adventure but yeah
movie [ __ ] had an incredible look to
it which
if you were gonna try to do that like
for a 10 episode series
expensive yes yeah we spare no expense
on that one
um so yeah at some point we're gonna
hopefully see speed racer back on tv
um
similarly the league of extraordinary
gentlemen you remember that comic book
written by alan moore
um
you know an artist kevin o'neill they
made a movie of it once they did uh sean
connery
which famously is the movie that
convinced sean connery to retire from
making movies that was it right he was
like undone who did he play alan
quartermaine or something yeah on
quartermaine and there was captain nemo
and dr jekyll and invisible man
why why hasn't disney remade 20 000
leagues under the sea
they keep trying it like seems like a no
[ __ ] brainerd you get yourself nick
cage make him play captain nemo
you got a [ __ ] cool ass submarine
nautilus and then you got like the giant
[ __ ] squid and [ __ ] like
how did how is this movie not being
remade every year and [ __ ] they hate
batman all the time but like
sharks
[Applause]
[Music]
you know
whales and manatees like you get to go
in the ocean that's inner space mark
it's uh apparently i i you know somebody
will correct me from wrong but i think
it's in the public domain at this point
yeah and so like anybody could do it and
i know hbo had a series in development
at one point david fincher was going to
make a movie for fox at one point
cameron wanted to do it at one point as
long as they hire nick cage that to me
is
there's your
cap nemo right there
who wouldn't watch that movie nick cage
chewing the scenery playing an organ
we better get their whale
implying that he's got a fish fetish
like troy mcclure and [ __ ]
that man [ __ ] fishes
um
all right so yeah
uh let's see
remember our friend friend of the show
matt shachman
he of the wonder visions
yeah
he
he was terry he's a lovely guy he had a
great ass show
he has been tapped to direct the first
two episodes of the upcoming apple tv
live action godzilla and the titans
television series that's what
yeah who's that for that's for apple tv
and so this is essentially like
the movies they've been making but now
they're going to series with it now it's
the sort of like interconnected stories
that they're now going to put on tv so
it's
according to the press thing following
the thunderous battle between godzilla
and the titans that leveled san
francisco and the shocking new reality
the monsters are real um this
monsterverse series will explore one
family's journey to uncover its buried
secrets and a legacy linking them to the
secret organization known as monarch
i'm sorry
i hear a lot about humans
i don't hear a lot of what i'm looking
for in a godzilla series which is
non-stop godzilla monster action
yeah well
i know a lot of people were like you
don't get it man you need the humans for
the story i don't i'm 51. i've seen all
these monster movies i'm tired of
watching them with people in them i just
want to see monsters beating the [ __ ]
out of each other that's good
make the movie 30 minutes long just have
them beating the [ __ ] out of each other
i'm gonna talk about the human drama i
don't care what little kid but friends
what [ __ ]
let's go and see titans clash that's all
that's it
simple math it sounds like it could be
it except
what i'm hearing
yes hearing a lot of family stuff you're
a lot of human stuff
i'm sure it'll be fine yes
uh so that's he's moving on to do that
which is being uh run by a fella named
chris black
who co-created the show with matt
fraction of the
comic book lore hawkeye
odyssey casanova
so forth and so on
um josh and chad is saying shin godzilla
is great and it's mostly human drama
it is shin godzilla is amazing what is
that
yeah i saw it on a plane why didn't you
[ __ ] step up for it a second ago
while i was [ __ ] all over it well
because the current because it's it's a
japanese godzilla movie and not part of
the american
what so it's is it a touhou movie i
think it's a touhou movie i think it's a
terrible movie but it's ultimately it's
it's
i saw it the same summer that i saw
chernobyl
and they are very very similar and then
it's ultimately a movie about
the inability of systems to respond when
humans need to take control
and it's so specifically a japanese
movie about the red tape that one guy
has to go through
in order to respond to the fact that
godzilla is being born in the middle of
tokyo
and it's this slow moving like god's
this [ __ ] egg that hatches or
whatever the [ __ ] it is and this
slug crawls out and they're like we
don't know how to respond to it it'll be
fine he'll go away and then the slug
begins to metastasize and get legs and
arms and then stands up and slowly
becomes godzilla and there's this one
guy was like i could have saved
everybody if you had just listened to me
but you wouldn't because you're all
[ __ ] salary men trying to keep your
phony baloney jobs and i'm trying to
save tokyo
it's wonderful this is a [ __ ] thing
that i could be watching instead of
doing this stupid-ass show yeah that
sounds amazing
it's dope it's awesome godzilla shin
godzilla i don't think it's streaming
anywhere you might have to buy it um but
it's dope
[ __ ] ticket sold i guess is it in
japanese
um yeah
yeah
yeah i think i saw a dub version on a
plane i'm used to watching dubbed
everything now i watch american [ __ ] dub
so
where's my subtitles
that so they show godzilla getting born
yeah
yeah why don't they call it
the movie where godzilla is blue
maybe that means origin godzilla or
something uh i i am not entirely sure
there is some english name for it as
well but i it translates to something
stupid or it was like godzilla afterburn
or some [ __ ] like that
um we have three more news stories one
of which is totally fun and the other
which are complete bummers
um the one that's totally fun is
christopher walken is going to be in
dune part 2.
oh right on who's he playing he's
playing emperor shaddam iv oh [ __ ] he's
playing the emperor
the spies must flow
uh that was jose ferreira last night
yeah
movie well good for him man i can't
[ __ ] see that that totally works he's
he's a guy that continues to have a good
time into his old age he was just on the
uh severance program
i cannot think of a more alien person
to play
uh amber [ __ ] on the fourth who has a
history with dune
in that the moby song
um
[ __ ] in
can't remember the name of that song
um
system of choice was that it whatever it
is walk without rhythm and you won't
attract the worm fat boy slim song fat
boy slam not moby you're right from the
spike
james where he's dancing yeah
and one of those lyrics is if you walk
by that rhythm you won't attract the
worm is that right yeah the reference
dude in the song that reference doing
the song
weapon of choice there it is good for
christopher walken better for
christopher walken's agent who continues
to [ __ ]
get my 10
they have one of the easiest jobs in the
world right because who don't want
christopher walken that's a dude or a
lady who just fields phone calls all day
yeah you won't walk in here where you
weren't walking walking
you ain't gotta sell walking nope
market sells
his damn self um what else we got um we
have two two deaths
um since last we podcasted um the first
being fred ward
fred ward man remo williams himself kids
indeed
uh
no bucks no buck
rogers that in in the right stuff where
he played gus grissom yeah
um yeah he was a staple oh he was a
um shortcuts
um
with altman um what else have i loved
henry and june
the first thing i saw him in was cast a
deadly spell
which i think was the very first hbo
made for hbo movie
um
in which he played
it was it was an alternate history
like
40s gumshoe detective story but in la
where magic was real
and so he played like h.p lovecraft um a
detective on the case for some woman who
you know disappeared and he gets hired
by the husband to find or whatever but
it leads him into a world of you know
sorcery and voodoo and all that [ __ ]
um it's like l.a confidential but with
like [ __ ] demons right which was
great it was really really good yeah um
yeah i think you can still find it i
think it's still i mean it should be on
[ __ ] hbo max if it isn't remember we
had at the video store at rst video
i passed it over many afternoons
yeah
um but he passed away i think natural
causes but it was a couple weeks back
um he lived a big life and and
made a lot of movies and stuff very
talented dude yeah and tremors of course
that's right
um yeah my favorite comment was
fred ward walked so john bernthal could
run
oh my god
i instantly speaking of which are you
watching we own this city i know you
told me i should last time and i still
haven't seen it it's i mean
it's it's diminishing and insulting to
say it's the wire part too but like it's
very not reminiscent of the wire but
like what a
what a
side-by-side bookend series if you will
about balmor um yeah it's been
really good the acting's exquisite and
he's phenomenal in it
um never let him play just like a nice
dude
just a guy
yeah the dude is like i got kind of
[ __ ] over or something like that like
it's he's just always so
you can't protect rick
involved in very extreme situations
you know as a character yeah can you
just be a guy
just kill like you would bought a house
as a wife and kids can can you make feel
the dreams of jon berenthal playing the
kevin costner part ah i sure would like
to see sam you you understand man
they're coming out the corn
[ __ ] ghosts man i'm kidding you this
[ __ ] ghost in my corn i just wanna
have a catch for my dad
[ __ ]
um you wanna have a catch [ __ ] off son
yeah well [ __ ] you dad
i'm gonna go [ __ ] your wife
um which does one of the most bracing
things about the opening of
of uh
the walking dead was that whole
oh i thought you were dead so i started
having sex with your friend
like it was just like a bad enough
dude's like where the [ __ ] i woke up oh
my god people zombies holy [ __ ]
then eventually like you got to deal
with the fact that like you know
um i thought you were dead so we started
a thing
yeah and she's pregnant and so
i don't know whose baby this is but it
could be shane's it could be rick's man
yeah that kind of soap opera was the
that was the right amount to throw into
the beginning of that because you're
like oh
yeah really i came to see people get
eaten alive but i'll stay
i'll stay for this weird love triangle
yeah this is a very hot gas
the field of dreams of it all does bring
me to the other um big passing um which
was raeliata who died yesterday i
believe jersey's own jersey zone at 67
years old far too young way too young my
dad died at 67 but he didn't look like
ray liotta ray liotta i just saw him in
uh
um
the sopranos movie yeah many saints of
newark yeah and uh he looked great um
this was surprising it came out of
nowhere somebody said he was in the
dominican republic and just went to
sleep didn't wake up yeah yeah i think
we're shooting a movie down there
um the wonderful
actor of course behind henry hill
everyone knows goodfellas but
this was a dude who when we were kids
this breakout movie was something wild
and and this is no [ __ ]
after that performance
a lot of people were talking about him
to play the joker um
yeah jackson you only see that yes they
were just like oh my god that guy could
be the [ __ ] joker and there was no
internet so it wasn't like random people
on the internet that was like from
hollywood i read that in like [ __ ]
people magazines and [ __ ]
um because his performance is so
you know [ __ ] he's horrifying in that
movie yeah like insane
um he's uh
um
in in field of dreams he played shoeless
joe right mm-hmm
yeah koster's dead one of the kings
right after something wild so he plays
like the psychotic
the boyfriend of melanie griffith and
something wild and then his next role is
like the very calm
very sweet spirit of shoeless joe who
just wants to play
[ __ ] ball yeah and then henry hill
and then goodfellas
like
i'm sure martin scorsese must have said
something
about his passing um i haven't seen it
yet but like
you know you need
very strong shoulders upon which to rest
the story of goodfellas you he needs to
be your way into that world
and your way out of that world as well
and
there was a sweetness
and a danger
to his
performances to like you know what he
brought to henry hill
that makes it one of the most imminently
watchable movies of all time
it's if you're clicking through tv and
goodfellas is on you just stop and you
watch and it has everything to do with
not just the filmmaking brilliance of
course of martin scorsese the
performances across the board but
his
sonorous tones man the dulcet tone
of our narrator who brings us
brings us into the flick in in weird
subconscious ways
like that gives him an advantage that
other actors don't have just giving a
performance because
there's a confidentiality to the voice
of the narrator like he's in it with you
he's in on it with you the audience and
stuff it's not you just watching
something
the narrator is telling you a [ __ ]
story personally so that connectivity
with that type of performance
with the movie that was so [ __ ]
beloved and remains
beloved a gold standard of a genre
to this day
made for a legacy where i'm sure you
know everywhere he went people were
happy to see that guy like whoa
man
he's good fellas
yeah jimmy two times i'm jimmy two times
hey you bust your cherry um
yeah
and to think that like
that's his third movie
and his co-stars
are robert de niro paul sorvino joe
pesci
and like all of them doing world class
work all of them knocking out of the
park and by the way lorraine bronco
lorraine bronco performances too and
she's given like a world-class
performance i mean there's no weak links
in that [ __ ] movie but like you gotta
have the shoulders of
[ __ ] hercules to carry that picture
with those [ __ ] titans in the movie
yeah still
you'll still have scenes be your scenes
yeah when you're in it with de niro yeah
yeah and then that movie has the best
voice over i think i've ever heard in a
movie
um because it's not it's not just
filling in blanks it's not some studio
mandated maybe the audience won't
understand like it is to your point it's
conspiratorial it's let me tell you
secrets that nobody else on screen knows
let me tell you what this character is
thinking and feeling and why
um it's it's the movie's a masterpiece
but if henry hill doesn't work then the
movie doesn't work
agreed um
what else was the end that i loved
i mean some what a career he had how
like over 30 years
if not more
um
amazing
amazing uh careers a sad [ __ ] early
loss
um
but uh the nice thing about
you know what he did for a living is you
always have that work
he'll forever be you know [ __ ] what
30 something however old he was when he
did good fellas maybe later
yeah i mean that was that was
1990 right yeah
19 [ __ ] 90.
remember when he's in the shower and he
finds out about he hears the radio on
1010 wins news about the
heist and
pounding the [ __ ]
shower like wall he's so [ __ ] happy
and [ __ ]
yeah i mean he's he's great in cop land
obviously stallone
he's great in hannibal
oh that's right he played uh
yeah his brains eating that's right he
has his brain [ __ ] spoilers
this is paul crandall
yeah
krendler kremler that's a
smoking aces
um
that was a good flick too
yeah now he did he did good work and he
always did consistent work
and he was on his way jersey boyd
i just read uh he was uh adopted like uh
he was in like a jersey orphanage or
something until he was five or six and
then he was adopted
um
you know like
um
but he come from where
like my family had
come from right up
in the newark area
uh
yeah a film legend ladies and gentlemen
um you know his voice
synonymous
with motion pictures you hear
you know
from uh from his law for as long as i
can remember i always wanted to be a
gangster you're that's
that's cinema right there iconic piece
of cinema and he
he got a big piece of that real estate
and it was all thanks to his talent man
uh big bucket of win as we say on
hollywood babylon for
ray liotta
um indeed thank you for your
thanks for your time
friend thanks for treading the boards
and giving us something to watch over
and over and over again
yeah man so uh so that
sadly as we are doing too often these
days
um brings the end to the news segment
that's a bummer um
what else is there uh the george carlin
documentaries on hbo yeah i saw the
first half of it i haven't seen the
second yet second half uh you might
recognize a guy
familiar friend of yours
um
the uh
you know
the kids in the hall have you watched
that were you not yet i was a kids hall
guy i saw mark hamill tweet about
i'm crashing you know
um i saw mark hamill tweet about well he
watched the whole run and loved it um
so i mean i i love the kids in the hall
uh i can't wait to watch it but
that's something i'm gonna get to this
week and stuff
now that you got time in your hand i do
now i got a little bit of time i the
good thing is when i came home and i i
got uh the covenant and stuff i uh
was working on a thing i put to put a
thing to bed
um a project that i've been
working on
and you know what it is but uh they're
gonna be announcing it soon
um
but uh very happy with
with what i and others
have done
fantastic yes but uh was able to do that
uh for a little bit while i was like
feeling [ __ ]
weak the other day but then after that
got
nothing like [ __ ] writing
you well-known speaking of which how
goes your [ __ ] gig
um the gig goes well i still can't say
exactly what it is
um
but uh but i'm off on script on my
episode of this thing
which is uh which is always a wonderful
slash precarious place to be
which i'm not sure if you have ever felt
this way but i always feel as if every
time i write a script and turn it in
they will discover
that i've been faking my way through it
the whole time
it was that for the last thing i did
like i was
you know um
there's
based on things that went before
you know my job on the last one is just
to be like and now this is tied and this
is tough all the loose ends are tied and
but um you know i had such a good
[ __ ] time
writing the episode because it has to
land the
[ __ ] plane so to speak
and uh oh
just
there's no better feeling than when like
you think you're like i think i got it i
think i did it
and then like i
sent it in but i didn't hear anything
for like two three days and i was like i
didn't do it like
and then i heard um
you know three days afterwards and they
were like oh my god how did you get it
all in there and i was like that's what
[ __ ] my wife says
[Laughter]
seems like your inappropriate tone to
take with executives but sure and i lost
that job they reported human resources
that was it so is he [ __ ] his wife
again yeah like don't tell dirty sex
wife jokes
[Laughter]
uh yeah i had the same thing on another
project where
in order to get a green light we owed
them a
format document which is basically a
bible which is here's what's happening
in the first season here's the shows the
characters all of that stuff um the
first episode in the second episode like
that's the quote unquote green light
package
and so i turned in the second episode
to uh to the production company who's
who's sort of being the shepherds of it
and similarly didn't hear anything back
for like four days until i got back a
note saying
you're so good at this i was like oh you
guys
i love you so much it feels nice to get
validation from people who are like hey
i'm not just a fan like i'm a pro
and
you did a good thing yeah
you you have earned your money sir and i
say thank you very much
um the blue beetle uh russell cook in
chad is saying the blue beetle suit
picks release did you see those i did um
they look like a blue beetle yeah very
much
you know the gut looks like the thing
yeah like they didn't they didn't like
black leather it they just [ __ ] they
blue beetle that guy i love that boy too
that's the kid from uh kobukai right
yeah i think so he's so good zolo or
something
yeah he uh he's a great choice man
nice
oh when i went to uh to go see top gun
two again today
um in non-40x but i went with my wife
and my wife was a huge fan that would
work
yeah
um but i saw a trailer i saw the new
trailer for the elvis picture oh
and i was like
i have to go with kevin to see elvis
because there's nobody else in the world
who gives a [ __ ] about elvis as much as
kevin does
so i need to sit next to him as he just
loses his [ __ ] mind let's narrow that
down there's no one in your world
much believe me there are people who
love elvis far far with
a respecter of the work he did in a
recent respect
but uh that [ __ ] movie looks
phenomenal i read a review today where
they said
this is one long never-ending series of
montages
and i'm like well it's a baz luhrmann
film like that's
that's what he does he does [ __ ]
spectacle and stuff
um i'm down i'm down to rent a whole
theater to go see that
spectacular spectacular you think
they're gonna 40x that [ __ ] oh
my god how much glitter can they get
those [ __ ] cats
on your face
austin butler though who was with us in
yoga hosers um
who's such a lovely kid
[ __ ] phenomenal in the new trailer i
saw like
you know
he's he's really [ __ ] sounds the part
it played to a 12 minute or more 20
minutes standing ovation
i saw
um good for that yeah i can't wait to
see that's coming very very soon yeah
the summer's gonna be packed man
including a new trailer for the jurassic
world uh dominion movie
which
listen whatever
it's gonna be whatever it is there's a
lot of chris pratt still holding up his
hands to make rappers not do [ __ ]
and like every dinosaur he comes across
he's like hey hey blue red
gamma this is the last one so might i
suggest he does this [ __ ] and one of
them just goes swamp
and then he's then from the rest of the
movie he's like
what i'm saying mark is he loses his
hand i would love that to happen i would
love him to captain hook his way through
the the back half of that movie [ __ ]
ballsy right like [ __ ] that would
learn him a lesson you know he's always
pretty cocky and [ __ ] and then he would
like you know then what's her name bryce
could see him you know as like
wounded and somebody who needs his help
her help and [ __ ] like that he's a
broken bird yes and [ __ ] you know
they can have a decent relationship not
one where she's running from t-rexes and
heels i saw
a thing that said
the end of the jurassic era
now
i'm imagining that's not quite the case
um so you had three
movies of jurassic park right yes and
now you've had three more movies of
jurassic worlds yes
and based on what we're seeing in this
third jurassic world trailer the
dinosaurs are just taking over the
planet
seems to be
would it be too far-fetched mark
to assume that there is one more trilogy
coming
of jurassic planet where it's just
[ __ ] like you know mostly dinosaurs
and only a handful of humans left and
[ __ ]
so the godzilla movie you've always
wanted
and oddly enough i'm like and that's the
movie
i'm pushing it more towards like you
know yeah like if we're in a jurassic
planet
you know
there's no more parks there's just
[ __ ] beast on beast action
because you know what they'll do then
then it'll be like we're on a on a
[ __ ] generations ship into the cosmos
because we've lost earth
and that's a bunch of people and then bd
wong is like guess what i brought with
us
dinosaur eggs and then it's [ __ ] open
and [ __ ] suck people's faces yep it's
just alien plus dinosaurs just mash up i
feel like they're going to jurassic
planet us next not not 10 minutes from
now but within the next
five years because
why would they leave this franchise
dormant
they never will
um but there's it seems like at least in
the last trailer that i saw the inciting
incident for the drama of this
particular episode is
blue
the raptor that had formed the bond with
chris pratt's character in the first
movie
now has a baby raptor like somehow bred
in the wild
and then the baby raptor gets taken by
poachers
and so chris pratt makes a promise to a
velociraptor that he would get her baby
back
and that's the movie
and it's like wait
is this because about like
these [ __ ] are taking over the planet
we're outnumbered oh i mean i'm sure
that's the backdrop but the drama is can
i get this baby raptor back
to her dinosaur mother
and some character actually says
did you make a promise to a dinosaur
and he says yes
um i am going to uh cry if that's the
story
i think it is him trying to go save a
baby raptor for his raptor buddy
yep blue
all blue my boy blue
boy blue
uh yeah i'm i'm gonna go i'm gonna i
i've enjoyed those recent jurassic movie
so i'll see this one as well
i uh
sure
i'll go [ __ ] dinosaurs man like
monsters [ __ ] dinosaurs how can i
um
that's the only news my friend that's
all the news there it is it's all the
news he asked for [ __ ] news
that guy right there he gave you that
that news man
leona wallace and chad said the real
drama is getting audiences to like chris
pratt again is that true people don't
like chris pratt
um i i think his his uh
his likability factor ebbs and flows
depending on how much and how loudly he
trumpets his i love hunting and also
guns
and also i'm a bit of a republican and a
conservative
there's the obscene of a few people who
are like uh
he's electric eliminator five says he's
over saturated i guess he isn't a lot of
things but
um
[Music]
oh and then somebody oh somebody brought
up his religion
yeah
well we'll just leave that right there
moving on we were having a wonderful
discussion about jurassic park and then
i did a wall
um
well
q a i guess so
but how do we
no is is will are you prepping for q a
uh discount banff man yes
hello you got ben you got you're not
there you got to say banff no no he's
not the bank yeah you can't hear it but
there is a a
as though i'm appearing like janet from
nbc's the good place
um
look buddy
we do things a certain way around here
if you're gonna come in you gotta say
bamf
i look i got a i got a phone call from
jc saying look
i haven't seen kenobi i'm at celebration
and i
i'm i'm i'm calling i'm calling it i
don't want him to ruin it for me
and he bailed threw this at me at 11
o'clock in the morning tell you what you
don't need to say bamf you need to say
when you pop in you say dilf
you're a dad that i'd like to [ __ ] so
pop out again then pop in when you pop
in go dilf
and then give a little like
like mr pillsbury
second draft is better so you pop out
and then you pop back on you go dilf and
then go d like
little chuckles
i just want to say a little part of me
is dying inside one more oh you do this
this is [ __ ] your moment this is how
you become the new banff man
here it goes the ladies and gentlemen
the introduction of
still
thank you for keeping the line clean so
that can just be sampled and then reused
if we ever have to resort to this again
a [ __ ] ringtone right there
um all right in order to uh
um which mccall uh do q a we need you to
pick questions you pick any i did pick
some i did and i don't i don't end you
jc's job in doing this
um but i like i like this one
you have doc brown's delorean to spend
one week in the past
wait wait wait wait what are you just
asking the question you just
yeah who's the question asking oh yeah
sorry you gotta kiss us first don't just
go stamp
i'm sorry
work us work our nipples kiss our neck a
little [ __ ]
chortle some more yeah
who's our first caller who's who's
asking nightshade halloway
nightshade holloway oh i remember old
nightshade holloway oh these stories in
the pittsburgh hallways
um what does nightshade want to know
will question for cleveland and mark
jesus yes question for kevin and mark
you have doc brown's delorean to spend
one week in the past
what week do you punch in before hitting
88 miles per hour
wow
wow
so
so that
part of the question is then do you go
anywhere in
time or do you restrict it to your own
life
do you want to relive a certain week
that you've already lived before
or do you want to go to [ __ ] like
1483 bc and just see what shit's all
about i honestly don't have as much an
interest in
going to a time period where i could get
like [ __ ] shot by a musket and die of
gangrene or whatever the [ __ ] fair
um
hmm
if we restrict it to just our personal
lives let's do that that makes yeah
um
i might
i might go back to
like the the week that i met
schwalbach i'm allowed to i know things
right like i know that
well yeah you're delorean so you're just
marty mcfly going back to the past i
might go back to that week that i met
jennifer and pay even more
close attention
uh than i did the first time around it's
worked out we've been together over two
[ __ ] decades but
you know that'd be a moment i'd be
curious about plus my dad would still be
alive so i could always like
reach but also don't forget you are your
current age it's not as if you are going
back and inhabiting you're not quantum
leaping
so we're just outside and looking in and
shooting marduk fly going back and
seeing his mother seeing his father
you know [ __ ] you know do i it's can
i see young version of me totally
but will that [ __ ] the time space i mean
you you can i mean you can do whatever
you want but jen would see
you you 51 year old you
like what the [ __ ] is that i'm hanging
out with the younger version of you and
now you'll be like who's this your dad
live
right
yes i'm his dad yeah
you haven't met him yet for real so for
now i'm his dad
i yeah i
i guess i don't know i might actually go
further back and see something from my
childhood
maybe one time we went to
like disney world when i was a kid or
something like that
there was a time i almost drowned my
father we were in a hotel pool and i was
standing on his shoulders
and he went under the water and then he
would like pop up and shoot me off but i
was
holding on to the ledge and i held onto
the ledge and pushed down
and i was standing on his shoulders not
allowing him to get up out of the water
and wow yeah it was crazy and then he
finally got up and was like my father
looked at me with terror in his eyes
like i have the omen
it just didn't occur to me that a human
being could die i was very young i was
like five or something like that
and uh
oddly enough he wasn't like because it
was the 70s and you could [ __ ] spank
a kid if you want oh yeah oddly enough i
didn't get spanked but i remember there
was a lot of like [ __ ] suspicion
from the old man for a while
he put the [ __ ] kid grace wait the
fat one tried to drown me
one time we were some pla where were we
like we were poor man but like still my
mom
my dad liked to that he worked at the
post office so he needed to get away or
else and go postal and my mom would
figure out how to stretch his salary
to take us on vacations and stuff and so
we went to hawaii when we were kids and
like i remember going like swimming with
my old man getting hit by a giant
[ __ ] wave and stuff i might do
something like that probably have a lot
to do with like the people who are gone
like my grandmother's gone and my
father's gone so i i might go hang out
in the
late 70s early 80s
also a time where you could get shot by
a musket and die of gangrene
i mean jersey in the 70s
you had to run fast because if people
could load a musket
they might just shoot
uh what about you
um
i think i would go back
45 years
to 45 years this week
and go see star wars and sit behind
me and my dad
i think that's what i'd do
because i don't think i don't want to
see would you guess oh
i didn't hear what he said now because
the guy the dumb guy wearing the legs
sooner or later your dad gets up and
threatens you yes
yeah
space man with your glowy watch and your
crazy mirror box in your pocket would
you not look at that while the movie's
happening you're sitting there holding
your [ __ ] eyes and rewards
look dad i did things
why are you calling me dad yeah and i'm
still alive where you come from you
could just show me those things then
[Laughter]
um but yeah i think i i think it's more
like the the experience of like yeah i'd
like to see that for the first time
again
and be there and remember all the sights
and the smells and all that
[ __ ] where i go
and we get a week in this thing
apparently we get a week
yeah man definitely definitely late 70s
early 80s my god i could i could see so
many cool things that like i took for
granted at the time like [ __ ] sitting
around eating pizza with my family
watching [ __ ] love boat
i'd that'd be [ __ ] worth
you'd just be in the window watching
yourself
cucking out on your family's eating
pizza young kevin's like dad
he's looking at us
he wants our pizza no no i don't want
your pizza i crave for happiness
and also that slice of pepperoni there
that pizza was only three dollars i
remember
do you have any vegan pizza what the
[ __ ] is he talking about yeah
i need something with no meat in it like
oh one of those
have some pizza there's no meat on it
yeah but there's dairy products that i
can't do that either animal products
like what happened what kind of cruel
future are you from what happened to the
animals why can't you have them anymore
did they finally rise up no
no
just like jurassic [ __ ] uh planet
yeah it's part of the apes but with cows
somebody else said the in the thread
before that
the jurassic sequels were okay but the
planet of the apes were much much better
yes
i had cosine you co-signed that yes
i'm not uh i'm a little i'm not i
wouldn't call it judgy but when it comes
to the plan of the apes they just seemed
too expensive to me
really yeah they all that cg they really
could have just
roddy mcdowell that lottie mcdowell
did it with a rubber mask and made you
did he played himself he played his son
he might have played zero at one point i
don't know but [ __ ] this dude he
could he could
fesp
through a rubber mask whose mouth didn't
even move that much and you believed it
was real
yeah i'm not taking anything away from
andy serkis at all he's a genius but
ronnie mcdowell
our generation annie circus
named rodney
mcdowell uh all right well that's one
question
yeah
well done oh my god i i'd already
forgotten
it's a surprise every time
h asks
you can choose one marvel and one dc
character to lead your lethal
weaponesque movie
whom do you choose
okay so
one from each universe
one dc one marvel and a buddy movie
um
batman and wolverine is my lethal weapon
oh wait do we have to mix it up though
do we have to make like legal weapon as
much as you should be
a black guy and a white guy i i wasn't
told a young guy
yeah what were the parameters of this
test
i still like my batman wolverine idea
i mean it's strong
it's strong
all right but who is who's getting too
old for this [ __ ] though
you know wolverine is functionally like
400 years old right right so he's the
one who's he's danny glover right
and [ __ ] the kid who's like you know
i lost my parents i'm gonna dress up
like a bat clearly
he's the martin riggs of it all
i would like those two guys to hang out
like what the [ __ ] are you doing
i'm just like a bad crime's gotta pay
yeah but but wolverine is more of the
riggs cause riggs was like you know do
you wanna jump
will you really
come on yeah nothing better to do and
batman while he may be
you know obviously dealing with trauma
in a weird way
wolverine is more the death wishy guy
the i got nothing to lose bub
yeah but we need maybe it needs to be
old batman
you know a dark knight batman is danny
glover he's too old for this [ __ ] and
[ __ ] wolverine who's ageless anyway
as are martin riggs my martin luther
sorry this is my movie but yeah that's
fine obviously i as always i turn to
mark for writing help
um yeah i mean i i think it goes because
wolverine isn't
i mean unless you do the version of
wolverine where he does have a death
wish and then it can't come true because
he can never actually die
like that's kind of fun
we're just throwing himself on buildings
there was no [ __ ]
parachute pants
balloon mat down there it's like yeah i
know
you killed the hostage yeah it's all
right
he was gonna die
i like my movie that i just made up with
the help of somebody else
who is your lethal weapon
airing
um
i mean i kind of want to do
like
barry allen and luke cage
like barry allen is the young kid and
luke cage is the [ __ ]
power grown up he's too old for this
[ __ ] he's too over this [ __ ] like would
you stop [ __ ] running everywhere it's
what i do man i got all the choice
i always just punch this [ __ ] wall
down it's like really that's just you i
could run in i could save everybody but
i gotta punch something
that could be fun
i like that
i don't like it as much as wolverine and
batman though i think i think you win
this round i don't know but yours is
actually closer to the lethal the actual
lethal weapon formula
yeah
i mean
or you do like professor x and swamp
thing
like i can't read your mind because i'm
an elemental i don't have a mind
i have ganglia
i'm uh am i a vegetable who dreamed he
was a man or a man who dreamed he was a
vegetable
not sure but i'd like to be able to read
you a moment it's dirty in there you
don't wanna
live a
facade we got uh another one there
dil dil boy dil
we're gonna do 10 questions tonight
you can't do that um all right uh the
last one is from
russell
cook
uh and their question is with the mandu
mando grogu
lone wolf and cub style theme that we're
seeing in shows now
what other franchise would you like to
see adapt the grizzly elder cute kid
adventures model
what other franchises right was that the
question yes and mine is jaws thank you
what do you mean what do you mean oh
because what do you mean because
i would pick the jaws franchise and we
actually see that all these jaws stories
are a
an elder
one of these mega sharks
that has to raise the younger one and
then each one becomes the subsequent
shark
as they ascend their way through
survival
in the warm waters they shouldn't be in
i know this is going to be controversial
because i spent a lot of time talking
about no humans in the godzilla
i need a lot of humans in a jaws story
gotta be a lot of brodies
and this is the reason why i'm not a
writer
i need no hoopers i don't i don't want
to see sharks raising sharks that's
that's [ __ ]
you know
there should be a narrator talking over
that
fair enough to be watching that in
glorious 4k not [ __ ] in a movie
theater going like when's he going to
eat some [ __ ]
um wait a second so
this is the lone wolf and cub formula
right old badass having to care for
slash rey's
young kid
aka archie bunker's place
sure
because technically he had to raise
stephanie by himself
and he was a crotchety old man and she
was a young kid who gave him a lot of
heart right but they didn't have to
battle anybody
he ran a bar
[Laughter]
could it be a precocious young black kid
i mean it's also pocky booster isn't it
it's also like every sitcom from the 80s
pretty much i think we've just
discovered that wolf and dub
trope goes very deep
we've got an old character actor and a
very young child what do we do now oh i
got one ooh
you know
it's very on brand for me
you got
an old alfred
and a young bruce wayne they did that
it's called gotham never mind
moving on
i bet you read like a great idea i was
like six seasons yeah
i think
i guess they did that one kids
um
let's see
professor x gene gray
um
i would watch
um a program where
uh professor hikida
had to raise a young buckaroo banzai
after his parents were killed by
hanoishan
nice
um
you know we were talking about him
before and [ __ ] but
you know who is also a very famous
[ __ ]
second generation character
[Music]
nice so what if the babe has to be
protected
what i'm saying like you know we always
get the story like hey christmas morning
he's born in a manger and then they pick
up the story when he was like 12 years
old and he starts going into temples and
laying down rules and [ __ ] and
showing off his wisdom you got a dozen
years in there
really unaccounted for
and during which some of it he's a
little baby man so [ __ ] dude
dude so here's what happens
uh
baby is born joseph mary mary dies in
childbirth
because why not well we're refashioning
this mary doesn't childbirth joseph is
like i can't handle this this
responsibility it's too much for me i'm
[ __ ] off because dads did that [ __ ]
in the old days and also the new days
but never mind
and so who shows up now to see a child
with no parents but the three wise men
who now have to raise baby jesus
to be
strong three men and a baby three men
and three wise men
[Laughter]
oh my god every story from cold mark
there's no new story under the sun it's
all a variation of [ __ ] different
strokes apparently
oh i'm keeping three wise men and a baby
that's pretty hot
i i think that's going to be my view a
skew short for your anthology for for
secret stash comics
hasn't why haven't they done
you know
a [ __ ] defending baby jesus
show
local club style like
who wouldn't watch that like christians
would be like yeah finally something
we'd get behind and non-christians would
be like i gotta [ __ ] say
what is happening here
are they trying to grow goo baby jesus
like joseph is doing like push-ups in
the shed like he's gotta get ripped in
terms of cue ratings for a character
we're not talking about jesus baby jesus
oh
that's like tom selleck and baby jesus
yes
you're not kidding man
and if you put a mustache on baby jesus
as you get later on in life forget it
like think about it everyone's always
trying to make a remake of something
because they're like the name's familiar
and the familiar name will help us get a
footing
what is more familiar than [ __ ] baby
jesus everybody knows the name of jesus
and also the rights are available
public domain don't cost nothing
wait catholic church
they don't own that character no you
can't copyright jesus
do tell
one of them is a baby
three wise men and a baby get me dancing
guttenberg and the other one mark
hollywood hung up on me yeah son of it
they don't like money
hold on
hollywood you don't like money
if you can't make money on jesus you
should be out of the making money
business and seriously he's one of the
most popular
figures
not even just of the 20th of the 21st
century of every century we've had
since he's been
born this has been
a playful blasphemy with kevin and mark
blasphemous here this is spitballing
you want like the mel gibson version
where he's beaten up and bloody and old
no
you want the muppet babies version of
the story man i think we can provide
that but with a little danger like with
a little
lone wolf and cub it's like somebody
what if it's the same michael the
archangel
who has to [ __ ]
oh angel defender
oh angel defender bro that's what we
call the show [ __ ] yeah
it's got angel of mercy
and [ __ ] touched by an angel ran for
a decade yeah not problematic name at
all
angel defender that's hot man nice
starring vegan center is it a law show
did david e kelly write it but no
it's not about an angel lawyer it's
about an angel who defends baby jesus i
mean to be fair lucifer was about the
devil who becomes a cop
did he become a cop in that show
basically he's like a consultant for the
lapd helping to solve crimes every week
so an angel defender like listen he can
100 be on l.a law
city of angels law firm so we go pitch
angel defender about say michael the
archangel you know uh lone wolf and cub
with saint michael the archangel and
baby jesus and they're like
maybe jesus is a hard sell but the title
angel defender who hot title like it can
you repurpose it to a law show
in which the lawyer
happens to be an angel
indeed so he's got to work the law from
the right side yes there's the law of
men and then there's the law of god and
can i make these two coincide
bro we should be proven
now these are strong ideas
that both a christian and a
non-christian audience can enjoy
christian audience because like finally
something for me non-christians who are
just like get the [ __ ] out of here is
that really a show
and then if we make it good they'll keep
watching and then the criminals who get
off on a technicality then get judged by
the angel defendant it's like if the if
the laws of man won't stop you then
listen you have eaten unleavened bread
on the sabbath buddy
he got away with that angel defender an
angel defender is like uh only for now
but god sees everything
yeah and then he asks me to take care of
it
no
he's a he's an angel and a lawyer he
can't be a vigilante as well oh he can
also be daredevil 100
oh my god it is daredevil isn't it
all of our ideas have already happened
that's a norelli idea everything else
has already been done
usually by different strokes
god damn conrad bane he stole all of our
juice a show is way out of its time
nobody gives it enough credit
lone wolf in cub but also in the city
and also in high rise with two brothers
instead of one
it just sounds like a real like 80s
10 o'clock show that
started on usa network for a couple
seasons or something yeah right after
burn notice angel defender
burn notice that's way too modern i'm
talking about this [ __ ] ran like back
during like son of the beach days
wow
when they were like we'll try it angel
defender
how to get on the board
somehow what's harry hamlin doing
[ __ ] good poll yeah oh man you get
perseus to play the angel defender
i think we got something
it also sounds a little bit like michael
the movie with john travolta
yeah but he wasn't in court
good boy he never went to court he's
like on the barn like doing like gentle
miracles for people that's the
brilliance of our thing is you mix two
things people love religion
two places people love going church and
the courthouse yeah
it's like do you promise until it puts a
hand on the bible it's like oh hello old
friend
bro
we're you know i'm i'm uh 51 how old are
you right now 50. i guarantee you before
we leave this best of all possible
worlds we see a show not called angel
defender but literally
about what we just described here a
process of elimination
somebody sooner or later is going to
pitch and get [ __ ] sold an idea about
an angelic one
it's highway to heaven but he's a lawyer
pretty much
and that show ran for a decade too yeah
throw in the good book
wait
is that the title throw in the good book
i mean it could be
i still think angel defenders better
yeah
well that's the name of the pilot
episode angel defender throw in the good
book
[Laughter]
and people talk about that pilot for
years to come they're like oh remember
phone the good book it's like our glass
menagerie or whatever
yeah like we shot a pilot god it was
awful but there's 20 good minutes in
there that we can
slip into another better [ __ ]
i'm just proud of myself for remembering
a conversation we had like two hours ago
um
we answered those three questions is
that all we got there dilfman
yes
those are the questions three
excellent choices my friend those were
those yielded wonderful responses my
pleasure angel defender 98 central right
after airwolf
what's the theme
i might come from a tall building on top
of it from a vine
cause i'm the unknown stuntman makes
eastwood look so fine
maybe we just borrow from fall guys
it's fall guy
doesn't have a stunt man he's an angel
who defends people
i mean also the angel defender who got
this guy off of whatever crime
you go [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] writes
itself uh i'm and now i'm surprised that
we didn't pitch fall guy as the lone
wolf and cub thing uh and a veteran
stuntman having to raise
uh young
you know 11 12 year old would-be stunt
kid
yeah a kid who's just like
you know he's he's a kid he loves to
roughhouse and throw himself out of his
houses and [ __ ] and he's like i want to
be a stepman when i grow up he's like
you're too little
[Laughter]
oh
skips
it's always the you know that it's time
to end the show when we're just amusing
ourselves
telling each other dad jokes that
everyone's just sitting here cringing
going like
have they talked about obi-wan did i
miss it yeah cause what are they doing
now i don't know they're
blaspheming and singing old theme songs
kabuki kid says bj and the bear but with
baby jesus instead of a bear
i mean you could do a modern day second
coming show
baby jesus like truck with jesus and can
you get greg abigan again
and the name of the show is
jesus take the wheel
that's not bad
that's not bad that's the thing that
he's saying
there's awareness for that plague i know
that's what we say when we go to the
pitch meeting when they made that show
give me a break people were like hey
i've heard of that phrase give me a
break you're right yeah no carter speaks
for me
i want a break as well
living single i've lived single too
i get it
um give me a break gosh you deserve it
time i made it to the top
wow you knew the second half of that
give me a break i'm looking forward get
behind me pull out every stop
damn on a happy ending i'm tired of
pretending well let them get the best of
me whoa whoa whoa
give me a break
the name is survival give me a break i
forget the rest of the lyrics but no you
got plenty
i'm sorry i'm sorry that's all i can
remember yeah
just
three verses in a chorus i didn't have
any more
i was actually deeply impressed i
haven't seen that show in [ __ ] 35
years
good theme song's a good theme song let
that be a lesson kids if you make a show
make sure you got a jingle because
and nobody does anymore but that's when
nobody remembers yeah it's true there
was a time when it was all jingles
uh there it is kids that's all the show
we got for you man did you have a good
time i sure did not show did you learn
some [ __ ] i sure did
um and hey we didn't get anybody sick
yeah because i was [ __ ] in a room
laughing and spraying [ __ ] ovid germs
all over the joint from the safety of
your own home you heard from me and mark
bernard and you heard us talk about
obi-wan kenobi um which is on disney
plus right now
um we don't get paid to say that i'm
just trying to be helpful and [ __ ] but
we get paid to say this give me the emmy
we want to thank our sponsor to show
uh uh the good folks at me i m
go to emmyeats.com
uh fat man and they're gonna give us
money off when you try
their uh five dollars five bucks off
they're plant-based ramen
that's good eating um
uh we uh you know send our best to a
baby banff man who's uh
just at that non-stop orgy called star
wars celebration balls deep in the force
oh god he can he couldn't be [ __ ]
he's so into celebration he didn't even
watch obi-wan gonna
it's like i can't leave the party to
walk the party too busy [ __ ] loving
star wars to watch storm
but his uh our you know him not being
around was our [ __ ] good fortune
tonight ladies and gentlemen because oh
my god
that meant that we got to hear from
dilf boy himself
will welcome give it up for the dad i'd
like to [ __ ] come on
you're welcome
there he is thank you for getting us up
online and
putting us out there into the world so
we can talk and [ __ ] it was my pleasure
um but uh there is no show without the
this this this [ __ ] every week
[Music]
i gotta figure i gotta draw my laptop
screen this little post-it note
the other side [ __ ] whatever you know
the guy who's not me in the box
yeah yours is easy you just go like that
but maybe it's this i just guessed i was
just like well we'll see what happens
you nailed it you know
yeah i'm wrong too i keep doing it wrong
this one's right
if you if you do all of it
like [ __ ] danny tario and [ __ ] just
[ __ ]
i got it nice
one that one you you i know you i know
you
um
sorry kids i i just had to get that
figured out
uh give it up for mark bernard ladies
and gentlemen thank you boys and girls
and that my friends is a fat man beyond
for this week i'm kevin smith i am mark
bernardin tune in next week same
fat time same
fat channel smodgest.com or youtube.com
kevin smith jeff's kiss everybody
may the force be with you
[Music]
yes okay and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens when jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith